une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités date site
jeudi on le je suis seul pour
l'introduction parce que c'est le temps
des fêtes pour tout le monde voir sa
famille inclut un dom le podcast cette
semaine et présenté par laura secord
vous connaissez sans aucun doute leur
autocar c'est vraiment le chocolat t'il
plus plus connu au québec puis au canada
plus largement au dessus de 100 magasins
au canada
laura secord cd chocolat et des bonbons
aussi de haute qualité se rendre du haut
de gamme
si j'étais heureux d'apprendre en
découvrant leurs produits dans le sac
nous envoyer que beaucoup de leurs
produits qui sont un régal par
inadvertance ça ça veut dire que y'a pas
de produits d'origine animale mais que
c'est pas voulu comme ceux c'est juste
que ça adonne de même fait que c'est
encore parfait s'accordent mieux en fait
pour moi et nous en voyons ça qu'on sait
bora fasse pas de case de les voir j'ai
tapé sur les juges qui sont sans
gélatine donc c'est encore une fois
c'est super donc on peut on vous offre
en fait 20% de rabais sur les produits à
prix régulier donc tout ce que vous avez
besoin d'un faire c'est d'aller où laura
secord en magasin près de chez vous et
mentionner le que vous avez entendu
cette annonce là dans le sens filtre
podcast produit par le studio sf bi vous
allez avoir 20% sur les produits à prix
régulier et l'offre et vallées du 26
décembre
donc je sais dans deux jours jusqu'au 14
février fait que vous avez un bon une
bonne période de temps pour sauter là tu
fait merci leur accord de commandite et
ce podcast ci sinon aujourd'hui c'était
notre partenaire du studio sfr
initialement voulait recevoir tous les
podcasts ont tous les podcasts ont en
fait qu'on qu'on produisait ici paris
par contre on n'a pas réussi à rejoindre
tout le monde fait qu'on s'est ramassé
avec on s'est vraiment c'est comme si on
était
avec un drame aux fidji 7 les deux
choristes du temps des jujubes puis on a
fait une genre de rétrospective de
l'année
une rétrospective des podcasts puis on a
eu vraiment du fun à faire ça ça le vire
un pas en partie tout le monde était
vraiment dans mon nom mais mme nicole
qui est venu le je regarde lui même pas
le seul dans un studio mais quand on a
une école qui venu parle un peu par le
podcast on en est revenue un peu sur
l'histoire des meilleurs sujets rémy
gabriel sur le podcast sur son pas de
casquette angels allait créer des remous
on en a parlé pas mal sinon sinon
c'était vraiment le fun c'était juste
relaxe puis sans plus attendre en fait
je vais vous laisser écouter ce podcast
le j'ai déjà trop parlé
merci à laura secord de commencer notre
podcast merci à vous d'être là nous
écouter merci aussi de participer aux
conversations laisser des commentaires
les saints laïcs les cds waiting sont
les applications audio et sans plus
attendre
bon podcasts et bonne écoute
[Musique]
c'est parti c'est parti hier six ans le
poste où on parle parce qu'on veut
éviter le temps d'un sans fil web
incessamment fond on voulait faire le
partait du studio sf sauf que leur
finalement un doute pas de casque on
produisait les halles un enfant fait
qu'un peut définitivement pas venir bord
d'abyane westerlo puis hadji avec
quelque chose d'assez ça comme virer en
tirer plusieurs enfants il est temps d
ouvrir en fait quand même fait que l'a
finalement si le thème est le thème sans
fil tous les autres dessins jeux on
pourrait venir ici la bière je peux pas
venir l'egypte et les affaires la bière
et gaston qui coule janvier ça a pas mal
été sur charlotte h lag et achalandage
like pour le bon mois qu'on vient de
passer quelques lags c'est de la bonne
bière pauvres est content est un peu
prendre un chat date puisse appuyer on
voulait faire oui cap de l'année
un week-end au rallye de l'année rempli
ses conséquences et qu'est-ce qui a fait
que ton année elle veut aucun nom mais
bush parlait de moi je parle une fois
que tout me plaît excuse moi tu a
planifié de parler quoi comme tous les
podcasts
ah oui j'allais pas ça peut compter
aussi ça peut compter aussi qu'est ce
qui est c'est quoi alors j'aime pas ça
commence avec moi je vais commencer
quand je vais te pompe est nommé
directeur adjoint de quoi semer allied
deux mois au pas de casse ou comme
d'armavia en allégeant toujours loin tu
étais où la davie même si aujourd'hui tu
as you drive
non j'ai eu mon vieux port et le torse
ouais ça a pas tant évolué je tombe à
point
je la connais pas ton mégot ya pas 200
dollars non c'est est encore ce qu'est
qu'on sait que dans les deux dernières
années c'était vraiment plus ma vie a
changé dans ce sens que comme j'avais
javel ans chez ma job pour une fois que
c'est plus sur la musique parce que
actually c'était correct avec les shops
tout j'arrive à vivre de tupi tout mais
dans le sens vraiment problème gallas
parraine aussi chelsea sera pas ça pas
tant changé depuis l'année passée encore
focus sur mes petites affaires on est
cette fois des projets soit avec lui
souhaite mais en fait seul je prépare un
petit album solo puis mais sinon j'ai
rien différent pour et j'ai progressé
j'ai déménagé avec lui - c'est vrai je
me jetais plus sur le pont était là
n'est pas aussi la puissa ça fait du
bien d'être un peu plus qu'un des
ménages ikeda moss affectées - ouais
ouais
ironie dans mes wanadoo ouais ouais je
suis quand même plus tranquille besoin
de pognon
non mais ça m'aiderait à béton bientôt
mais c'est ce que je me suis dit je me
suis garé devrait profiter du temps des
fêtes plutôt chica règles je suis pas à
plaindre non plus on s'entend j'ai
profité de mes enfants j'ai continent
très petit temps faibles en janvier le
joueur comme faire des moves a checké
bon qu'est ce que je fais c'est sûr que
je pense juste qu'un petit temps partiel
pourrait m'aider même temps je peux pas
de quoi que tu répondais je m'en prenais
un petit job pour fassi a tenté je veux
tout moi mon but dans la vie c'est sûr
j'aurais toujours vouloir faire de quoi
que j'aime je me bats pour faire quelque
chose que j'aime ça c'est sur le sol
chaud je vois pas retourner à aller
faire de quoi juste pour le charisme
micro un mais deux qui est parfait comme
c'est bon c'est bon je le jeu mais vous
autres les autistes rim la sfef et se
fait un peu attendre pas mal mais ça va
être source de revenus principale ou
alors espaces et les shows ouais c'est
ce que paul chauvin et on s'arrête pas
mal a justement parce que tu dans ce
milieu
t'as pas le choix il m'a tendu et de
l'argent ce garde-temps qu'acheter comme
un écureuil est mise de côté pour les
mots les plus les plus froids les
connaissent une secte dans le fond c'est
ça se passait sa départ il ya eu débat
justement mais dès qu'on a fait
plusieurs shows bakaba glaçante avait
mettons deux gros show très payant avec
le titre c'est comme des passes de cash
des fouaces et puis comme on ne se sent
en avant mais aussi une coupe d'un show
plutôt fait là pour décembre on n'a pas
eu ce jour je me souhaite enlever les
quatre dents de sagesse tu pourrais pas
le rap et le ça va mieux mais c'est moi
qui ai fixé c'est tout un peu de moyens
mais en même temps j'aime ça tu sais
j'ai tellement de liberté puis comme je
te le dis si j'aime trouver un petit
temps partiel en décèdent pour continuer
a quand même droit que ma musique parce
que c'est ce que je peux ce que je veux
pas gérer le faire mais je veux quand
même toujours pas de quoi que tu sais
que je me fais du fun fact peu importe
c'est quoi ouais pareil bin ouais je
parlais mais ben watson qui m'a dit men
se jeter comme je pense j'ai pas le
choix et doit recommencer quand même un
world they come parce que c'est un peu
s'est passé est stable mais en fait ils
ont été comme notre bébé en fait baby
c'est le bébé en lui même le dance main
il aurait fallu claude béchard est
toujours un pays comme ça sincèrement
non faut pas son agent il faut que tu
passes tes limites il faut que tu ailles
plus loin mais voit ses cages
claude même klose et ses jardins invités
au party c'est quoi le petit pays
semoule
s'il y en a qu'on peut voir la petite
série de la dance 2010 watch the throne
scène estimons à bonn ouest aux
habitants je passe aussi cette lutte et
de toutes faites le jeu paraît pas sa
place 2010 oissel me semble qu'il y en a
fait la majorité des gros buts mais je
ne savais pas qui je pensais pas qu'ils
qui était si à l'aise dans ces trucs à
lui petite rue calme et ton petit pas
mais j'en parlais un peu développé ce
matin puis quatre cas qui kaki venu nous
parler qui accueille avec milliwatts il
poussait même pousser ses limites
om et il fait bon être parce que les
gars de la classe en solo si son écran
l'infecté may be what son album il fou
fou sur la destination de foule au final
mais c'est sûr que je ne sais pas
comment ça fonctionne et est un gros
groupe domaine
ils font tellement chaud que jamais sur
lui toute la gamme nom complet avant
pour les gros gros choc ce qui clôt
franco cette équation trop le bio claude
là dedans c'est quelqu'un m'a pas dit
mais vous autres la ville de longueuil
vous ont pas rejoint après après qu'ils
ont du respect d'un combat qui mais
j'aimerais bien semaine c'est pas un
petit contre lui non non je ne sais pas
si con bien qu'ils ont fait mais n'ayant
pas de faire deux pièces ça peut nous
permettre comme des papiers nautique est
renoué notre amitié qui se disait à
cause des tickets de stationnement il
faut qu'on en parle de ses sites laisser
le temps c'est une plateforme pour seuls
six avaient nécessairement pour sauter à
la corde sans fil les gars à mouvoir je
sais j'ai la plus belle avec la ville de
longueuil
j'ai l'air - qui est en jeu mais je me
suis dit je bluffais clé je vais
commencer les choses sérieuses genre
liszt le d'intrus le rival moindre
apparu sur le podcast la vue le jeune
homme et une coupe des rues
c'est la foi c'est pas le moine c'est la
construction que s'est donnée le pis
depuis qu'ils ont faite la construction
ils ont mis comme d'un côté à chaque
jour maintenant la semaine soit tu peux
pas attendre lundi mercredi vendredi
faute pas eu de report de ce bloc fait
pas le mardi et le jeudi
bon c'est un mort à chaque jour dit pas
que d'un côté mais de ce côté là tu peux
de paquets de 120 minutes si tu vis le
foot changera chaque sens à chaque sens
du but et on n'essaie pas une rue à
montréal l'infection ça veut dire qu'ils
vont le chercher le tout je lève le
matin ça te fait chier tu regardes tu
vas pas à partir de 10h faut du temps
son charme et si c'est comme ça regarde
la rue en deux jours il faut deviner que
tu peux pas nier comme 3
mais toutes les autres rues plus loin
lyon des vignères comme les seuls
reconnu comme fuck tech ce que des
formes étranges comme je me suis engagé
avec un maire c'est de la grosse brute
qui est à côté commerce je sais y est
pas très longue et si on n'est pas à
côté du mans et champlain matin on voit
ce qui arrive ça cause de l'hôpital je
pense à l hôpital charles-lemoyne et
manon et je pense qu'il est un génie
civil je pas trop quoi là dedans qui
ajuste fillon juste pas de chéquier
bonjour par professionnalisation des
tickets bah ouais ouais ouais c'est ça
mon âme a réussi ce qui marque et puis
kottmann life officiel mais comme au
début je trouvais le terrain
en terme en juillet de juillet jusqu'à
jeudi un jean troué au moins trois
quatre mois je veux rejoindre 12 6 4 oui
c'était sous l'assiette le ca fait sa
fête au loyer me coûte 150 pièces de
plus par mois le 150e trois cdc
c'est pas des parkings c'est de la
vitesse ok jean-paul genre deux ou trois
par le système complet alors la police
fois mais c'est toute la chaîne des bien
sûr qu'on veut que tu partes avec moi
c'est ça je repars avec la bière tantôt
puis on commet j'en viens en force mais
mais ouais c'est ça géant japonais ou
trois par année
mamadou bah non même pas aux motos et
aux motos champagne pas parce qu'un moto
mais tu t'en rends compte c'est mettons
le campus romance à 100 dans une zone de
200 métiers ou de 90 tu le sens moto tu
le sens du sud c'est un auto des fois tu
journal d'un petit goût de la musique tu
es rendu à 185 a380
non mais je dirais que 14 530 pour le
facilement exact même dans des zones
d'étude de 50 sous les 115 je fais
perdre mon permis en norvège si j'ai
déjà compter sur le côté je sais pour
podcast ouais non ac c'est dans le fond
et selon le cas la norvège avec avec ma
blonde puis elsa betriu puis on se
promet là bas moi je conduisais le char
dans le fond qui est humaine la bosse
fallait conduire crissement pour monter
au nord du pays
c'est qu'on avait un bon un bon 2500km
l'a peu près l'équivalent du rhône en
flamme et puis on avait une semaine pour
faire ça les retours fall avoir du temps
aussi pour arrêter chile là bas les
c'est pas des autoroutes sur des petites
routes
croiser enfants qui font tout le pays au
complet puis c'est ridiculement bas la
limite de vitesse à un point tel que la
première journée je pensais que c'était
en miles or on sait que c'est en mille à
l'heure
tellement c'était là mais c'est en
kilomètres heure s'effectue très serein
et si l'autoroute qui roulent en ligne
droite puis une vibrante et un autoroute
entre guillemets c'est comme sur une
route de voir et à deux voies qui
roulent en ligne droite à 50 km heure
pendant que 2,5 km tu peux pas dépasser
vraiment sont maintenant le tu peux
dépasser tu peux dépasser mais tu
dépasses sur une ligne jaune pointillés
mettons hockey parce que c'est ma tante
se dépassent la limite la bosse qui sont
ce qu'ils sont ce sont graves
cinq ans mais j'ai un ami qui habite en
norvège puisqu'il m'a expliqué après que
ne soit fait arrêter si tu te près des
chances de s'arrêter parce qu'un gars
est quasiment il ya quasiment jamais de
politique tchèque le radar parce que les
gens respectent la vitesse ce que moins
cher et pas fait finalement en étant du
nom de 50 j'étais à 80 trop ce qu'on
s'entend ici c'est pas dit un mot pas un
prénom c'est ça qui était à 81 tournoi
sur une zone de 50
je me fais arrêter là comme nous en
faire part active ne souhaite pas il ya
83 50
ça va vous coûter 250 pièces la faute là
quand je vois les policiers y étant
jolie dans tous ses états les gens ils
bout ils parlent fort il parle au monde
autour de lui ce qu'avait km autres
c'est comme une opération le faire une
queue de policiers plus le jean nicoli
ce malgré six points
il me fait sortir du champ mais même
dans son char à lui jouera sa banquette
en arrière place mes joueurs hissent
m'aidera à me poser des questions en
anglais les jalles c'est quoi comme que
vous faites ici pis pour que vous allez
je roulais à trouver d'accord je voulais
trop vite mais loin et excessif
vraiment ils sortent choix qui revient
tout le temps avec une feuille qui dit
qu' il peut m'enlever mon permis
à moins que moi juge que c'est excessif
si je viens d'un autre pays avec si je
t'ai norvégiens y partagent mon permis
d'atteindre par mois
83 ans entend il a déclaré me dit
s'appeler dealer maintenant toi tu peux
plus conduire ici tu peux plus conduire
en norvège puis il faut que vous me
suivez jusqu'à cour municipale parce que
votre ticket tu vas être trop élevé pour
que je puisse le faire ici fait qu'on
conduit jusqu'à cour municipale avec lui
c'est un autre qui ont été conduits on
arrive là on attend dans le parking
finalement on y arrive dans le monticule
à ses onze mériteront mais on se met
trop je finissais quoi cheikh sur mon
google pour changer les limonest 1700
pièces coûte 100 piasses fait que
j'appelle mon ami bruno serait comme un
email
j'ai une poignée un ticket de 1700 pia
semaines on était supposé aller voir
cette journée là je fais là on va
arriver ben trop en retard les faits qui
finalement lui me dit mène à 85 dans une
zone de 50 selon la loi et mon pagne à
83,85 il t'amène 30 jours en prison mais
cb en fait je comprends c'est une ré
notre pays mais il ya d'autres c'est
bien toi qui as tu d'autres affaires de
même exemple je trouve ça salit sied
dans le fond il me dit est dit tu sais
tu combien d'accidents sur votre si je
regarde c'est probablement vraiment pas
beaucoup avec boulimie des vitesses me
regarde fait vraiment pas beaucoup
pas de réponse un peu partout qui est
dit ici c'est quand à la règle
tout comme la convention non écrite qui
tu peux aller 20 km au dessus les
remettons roule à 120 mm à ce que tu as
à 19 kilomètres au dessus de la limite
petit rechain exemple même le rapporte
même pas cessée 135 mai mais ça roule à
130 5 en remontant molloy venir le cache
de chasse avant des fois je ressens 40
pour la trempe de trouver la limite
c'est super c'était à la limite même de
5 kg à la limite ça maintenant dans une
zone de 50
mettons ici tout roule à 80
le 5 ans c'est non je suis d'accord je
vais trop vite même pour ici je voulais
trop vite cpie jeu comprendra peut-être
pas 1700 la torture la khadra 23 ici
dans une zone de 50 tonnes ce qui est de
300 pièces sûrement plus maintenant ces
pratiques de 500 places de 5 à rouler à
70 mais sa vie j'ai eu dans charente
c'est plus que deux fois mais toi que
c'est pas mal mieux frapper un enfant me
up when mais moi j'ai eu ce dans une
zone scolaire sauf que moi c'était 50
je me suis pas désiré ya 50 ans le 30 ça
allait vite puis c'était je pense
étaient 140 150 pièces puis deux points
communs mais si j'étais à 50 mm je me
trouve bon j'ai jamais perdu deux points
je me suis fait arrêter par mois c'est
dit et moi c'est le parking parking sens
au jack là dedans tu confonds pas les
six fox la route arrêtée en dresser le
gagnant d'audi ont laissé partir
ouais c'est vrai que sa gamme go cats a
voulu sucer le policier le pourrait
c'est pour ça que ça fonctionne et ça
marche non ça m'est jamais arrivé je me
suis déjà fait arrêter pour maintenant
des vérifications que ça a donné matonge
projet pour mon permis ou un chute d'un
mois même où j'avais gens et non ce
n'est pas tout à lui ramène tout le
temps des années folles
bon en même temps c'est vrai que avant
ou des jeux terriens non mais no joe qui
s'étaient introduits via je pense
monsieur chez vous je sais plus mais
c'est la madame hans une madame qui
rentrait comme qu'elles sont allées
chercher son cash commun ou qui
cherchent à côté ben je me réveille
je la regarde plus avec un père la
police déjà la panique et moi je me suis
accroché la police est venue genre est
ce que je me tape à droite dormir ici je
me suis bien
il fait froid j'en oublie que moi mais
non mais je sais pas qu'est ce que ça
veut dire une broche pense mais je me
rappelle plus si ça fait une couple
d'années c'était vingt appartements à ce
moment là ouah mais pas vraiment pas
dans cette ville où je sais pas ce que
je faisais là je me suis plus le barde
et twitter ont défait d'un podcast on
put your hands up vie moi j'avais
j'avais le menacer sauf le gema blond
blanc ça fait du bien ça permet de vivre
plus longtemps avec sa table en main ne
doit partir belge
ironiquement on n'en parle pas ben ben
ouais mais maintenant c'est un feeling
ben parce que je me rappelle à tapis
rouge était le nom c'est son ami bush
avec mélo mais il y aussi notre homme de
fille alia qui était venu pendant que tu
as finale finale tout comme à tous ces
billets la brosse et c'est drôlement
vraiment que tu peux pas inviter des
amis
non c'est ça pour le tapis rouge c'est
vrai moi je mettais infiltrer un peu
mais pas infiltré j'avais comme
participer à un concours pour être au
tapis rouge
et puis je sais pas comment on avait
tellement bien fait ici je parle avec
les live plutôt que finalement je me
suis fait inviter pour être au tapis
rouge mais je pense que l' il savait pas
savez c'est un ami d'adamov nous autres
et l usman c'est lui qui est parti lui
même moins pendant 3 semaines évoque une
crise d si j'étais beau tapis ils ont
tout pris mais planifié cosaques sont
ils savaient que je rate rien mais qui
ont tout planifié la sortie du fisc lui
ai dit moi je refusais pour faire parce
qu'on avait un taux monte à fac ont
profité pour fadela ont apprécié par des
montages vidéos tout ce que tu veux
justement ta présentation d'adamou
claude fantômes dans le public -
il aimait la musique de l'express
pétiller crayon titi on tue tout prévu
la classe ça faisait comme par les
besoins le monde était comme quoi c'est
un beau tapis rouge souligne adam où il
veut puis moi je n'arrêtais pas de nier
ou parce qu'on a pas besoin d'en parler
j'arrêtais pas de nier à tout le monde
que non ça par rapport aux autres mais
ça peut être changée à strass castres on
dirait que dans toutes les éditions tout
le monde se connaît je sais plus trop
long direct monde et animer des rouge et
noir tout le monde vole abu dis après sa
bonne étoile
occupation double maintenant je devais
500c convaincu par contre j'aimerai cet
environnement lui je voulais qu'il ya un
mois je serai trop beau mais moi j'étais
crise serait trop pas je sais pas je
pars je pense je suis très proche penche
de vénérer anxieux l'adapa c'est éponyme
en a parlé à ses le nom si vous étiez
enfermez vous aviez rien on est là c'est
automatique
ouais c'est le dix ans je pense que ce
serait du genre à jouer en tabarnak la
gagne et je peux les moules moi j'ai
trouvé un peu factor c'est que le monde
ni kpata un peu parce que okello t'es ok
je pense qu'il y en a qu'on était quand
même chien un peu de vin caméra mathieu
puis tout le confessionnal mais ça c'est
ok je comprends qu'ils ont un peu abusé
maintien en france aux states l ancrage
dans la salle hero games pour gagner
parking 500 mille pièces arrêté ni oui
ok tu vends du rêve le mais arrêtez de
tout vous mentir je vois seulement moi
je jouerai pour gagner mes autres années
si on joue tout on est trop stratégique
mais c'est celui qui paraît le moins à
voir l'acte c'était ta de la stratégie
coup si tu exprimes la moindre aide
d'autres ta relation qui vont l'utiliser
c'est sympa mais vous c'était vraiment
plus frêle il je trouve un accord c'est
juste que
je pense que c'était un de ces
différences ça fait dans ma tête il nous
ça fait trop d qui n'existe que parce
que bollywood et d'avant j'avais jamais
écouté ce même si c'est à blainville les
médias sociaux fait que ça change tout
le moins surpris y avait aussi le fait
que si c'etait pas même pas le même
diffuseur je pense que tout a changé
tva c'était un matin je pense qu'on
était le nouveau d'une nouvelle base
nouvelle ère d'aude et puis je pense que
nous on s'attendait à rien c'est ça ta
lettre quoi oui on sait pas comment ça
marche est en fait un peu trop ce qu'ils
vont changer dans les affaires déjà moi
j'avais aucune crise dit c'est quoi la
maison de l'amour par exemple bleus ils
ont eu le temps de voir simple plus ça
veut plus je pense que plus le monde
s'envoler pour jouer puis plus le monde
savent qu est-ce qui est qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent fois rendu là bas plus le
monde savent aussi qu'est ce qu'ils font
en sortant mais c'est surtout ce je
pense à mon lot parce qu'il est
influencé le fun enfin la musique seule
fois vous pensez que c'est un bon choix
c'est vrai on a parlé de ce super on n'a
pas parlé mais non mais moche
j'aimerais savoir le vrai parce que
c'est ce qu'on disait autrefois tu sais
moi je suis chez moi je suis toute ma
vie puis même depuis qu'on est qu'on est
jeune je l' ai jamais parlé mais mon
instinct
au delà de mon esprit cartésien mettons
le tiche capable de pas avoir un one man
est juste parce que cette soirée serait
le fun parce que je sais que le
lendemain matin quand je me réveillais
j'ai toujours eu sur le type d'homme
yopougon toujours eu si je faisais plus
que ph
et puis suit plus
l'homme frontale affecter la prise de
décisions genre il va plus je suis plus
je sais pas j'ai plus impulsifs c'est
peut-être plus proche de mes émotions en
plus que ph
je vais peut-être plus dépendants
affectifs la mairie je suis plus j'aurai
plus le j'ai pas besoin de sentir que
quelqu'un m'a crié tu as besoin de pau
j'ai besoin d'une pause
mais j'aime autant que la bo vu que
cette association que j'aurais tellement
aucun contrôle
je pense que je vis ce domaine d'action
honnêtement ça te fait cette fait vivre
des choses que tu es comme bon moi ça
m'est arrivé puisque plus souvent dans
ma vie d'avant les expériences que chez
gvt aucun contrôle
mais à ce point le disent parce que tu
n'as aucun contrôle mais qui peut juste
comme te mettre à courir un kilomètre et
est juste plus la même place ouais mais
le parent ne peut juste pas bougé non ce
matin par le contrôle mois plus et est
enfermé seul c'était la première fois
que je mets toi même tu sais que je
pense que ce qui pourrait jouer pour toi
ouais c'est que t'es pas compétitifs
comme moi je le fais toi il pourrait
arriver quelque chose mais nous mettons
la fille que tu veux pour être en train
d'aller en aide avec un autre mais chose
que je sais ça ne mettrait pas en
tabarnak
je pense qu'il commande nous deux pour
possiblement moins en termes de
compétitivité et en plus comme toi le
tout encore il s'aime et on sait
maintenant les jeux n'auraient pas
accepté de perdre six jeux issus d'un
mois le jeu pas capable de juste perdre
quelque chose 500 m en tabarnak
je veux jouer pour la première fois un
jeu vidéo contre quelqu'un qui joue tout
le temps puis il va perdre
m c'est juste la fois je me suis nourri
tout temps même comment tu m'avais ces
quelques mots ni fallait comme prouvé
que son groupe était bon pts me suis
arrivé à eurodif en date la fois les
eaux calmes mais c'est pour ça que c'est
sexy ce tonton speech japon 30 juin
jusqu en baroeul crise vous me
connaissez je vais pas commencer le 3 e
tout déçu qu'un mail vous attendez quoi
que je joue le viol en vigueur en
saveurs
mais il fallait il fallait faire oui
djar djar de kato de karaté couche de
vingt mois c'est devant jesse tous tes
devant alex cross puis quand tout était
complet
ces labos mène une activité ses rangs un
beau challenge à ses acquis et cela que
va faire le meilleur cas tu as voté par
les instructeurs vont avoir une instit
et dans un genre de resto malades avec
la fille tu sais moi même si comme genre
j'ai regardé les mouvements gameplay je
maîtrisais touche les mauves adamo ygout
fera équipe avec les amplis qui lui
demande rien je me trouvais ça drôle
vient le temps de faire le 14 juillet
oblige les trois causes au regard des
liquides et des banderilles rebelles la
réaction mais genre c'est sa direction
lui ces gens aux green bay fait ouais
non mais parce que j'ai pu revenir à la
première question à base séquentielle
après ce match je dirais que parce que
toi dans le fond te sortir avec un non 2
en 4 1 3 4 1 vous êtes laissé combien de
temps 1 1 avant rodez - après ça tu pas
rôdés aux espaces french deux filles sur
viège les pets tp s'est passé je me
rappelle il ya la nuit de l'amour qui
avait juste j'avais pété à côté peut
être pas de sens de lancer si ce n'est
pas la fille et je peux seulement
well as alten qui monte à la télé sur la
dame au keeper depuis fait un bouclier
avec son cousin ont trouvé ça fait
classe et se situait sordo des bleus
c'est que ça a pris en été c'est une
unité de sortie de born on en janvier je
retourne avec la question avant l'été
fait clair avec un mois après au des
limites même il ya même preuve il n'y a
pas profité de son vedettariat
mais comment ça s'est passé mettons pas
ce qu'est ce que vous étiez encore en
contact 06 jusqu'à m'emmener avec lui je
pense on s'en aller chez ma mère ont
sonné rejoint de cendres est qu'à une
sortie au fait que je sais pas quoi puis
jeudi preuve d'amour
jeudi à 17 passes menton c'est le
jugement j'avais acheté mon seul shaker
je veux rien savoir
tu avais acheté ton sec acheter mais
comme c'est fait je l'amenais bush s'est
dit jeudi pas potentiel je vais appeler
un numéro de téléphone ça fait 1 à
appeler au numéro qu'elle me rappelle
bien sûr c'est par elles mêmes même
peachum je m'en suis un métier forages
ok je l'appelle le répond est en rien de
faire l'épicerie où je peux acheter des
rames est sûrement avec la table on est
asiatique pour l'achat tout en les
aidant même foi kiné puis c'est bon
crise ponctuelle à voit sa voix 17 qui
sont bien là je suppose à la fois comme
un lot je pense pas qu'elle m'avait
encore dans son téléphone non enfin je
sais c'est dans son coeur mais peut-être
mechmache comme devenu plus amie avec
table justement plus dans cette année là
bas c'est ce qu'a ramené des poubelles
gigantesque du mcdo dans l'appartement
ce n'est pas complètement tort celle à
travailler de nuit quand j'arrive avec
une poubelle du net de plus que la
grosse crise de poubelles moi j'irai à
la rame je suis le plancher à toi même
je suis moi même pour une grosse
poubelle en plein milieu de la crise et
l'as cannes où trouver car nous traitait
tout le temps d'investir 26t sommes en
relation
je sais pas mais vraiment pas loin mais
chaque libraire quand je l'aï appelé la
fête que moi je les certitudes qui était
contente le gisent toujours hector
d'études à l'école non gypsum à coco
cocoon aller retour inattendu genre
ouais je suis dans le club de mon
arrivée je pense comme trois jours plus
tard au china china town en panne des
dumplings de à s'asseoir mme dumont le
questionnement le chemin bas je dois les
comme hockey disputé 14 h 04 de ce type
à gaza et pour ça je t'aime typhoïde caf
préférence en s'insultant saint-menges
dirait qu'on arrive à un an après comme
cette part lancera cinq minutes si bondi
après ce
dans la première soirée vous revoyez
puis de suite vous savez les deux
gouvernance ans après un échec
c'est justement parce être par les
oiseaux je ne pense pas change pas ça
qui me avec à eau des petits trolls
jeunes douche se passe comme ça on sera
trois mois 3mois panier en dessous on
est les frères trois mois toutes les
phrases le les frileux ça tout ce qui
est dedans ça toi ce qui est dans tout
ce que tu as tout au moins ce kit à tous
et à tous et ce qui t'a tout état - non
mais c'est ça parait il veut peut-être
trois mois à qui vous avez une petite
activité une fois de temps en temps par
ce même par deux semaines tu vois la
finale puisqu'en une nuit de la mode
mais devant tout le québec au complet
jusqu'à d'amour avec avec ta blonde
mannequin qui est réalisé que c'est
sorti comme bali à bali cet été mais dis
que sa clinique niveau m des feuillets
les plus belles fesses mais comme la vie
c'est pas seul on va plus loin que
c'était le contraire je pense en vie
cinq sa pratique comprend ce mois ci à
chaumont ça n'est pas le 6 mai
pas pour plus de 10 kg en battant un
autre fois que je me dise émettons des
traces et ont donné une fille ou york
oui vraiment quelqu'un que je me dis je
ce serait ma blonde
je suis une question sur une question
d'être table on nous pose c'est celle
qui est une question d'être ta blonde le
temps que tu es là bas parce qu'il faut
pas que tu penses tu t'entends pas sur
le point et l'éthique moi le premier
mannequin sortie de l'oeil et fallu
qu'on ait fallu concilier semaine de
concerts punk donc on se redécouvre
quand c'est comme s'est pas cassé le
monde le tout ce que tu vis là-bas c'est
pas discréditer parce que ça dure pas
apprécié mettons c'est vous autres
alix la bouche il ya quelque chose qui
en découle une quelque chose qui s'est
passé pour vous pas de discréditer parce
qu'ils sortent ans puis vrai très sexy
c'est vrai là bas on sent qu elle se
soit pas apprécié par c'est sûr qu'il ya
vraiment là bodin trois années qui
arrêtent et tablant désormais c'est
encore moi je lui avais mis 200 pièces
pour que moi j'allais aux auditions
qu'elle fasse le mieux que je pouvais
pour pour être pris au sérieux mais moi
je suis prêt à mettre de st ce que vous
êtes prêts à côté chacun sait les
bourses pour que pour que je vais gérer
le jass ph sont en voyage ensemble en
asie et qui puis on ne te métro déjeuner
puis j'ai dit même toit de l'audition le
débo même défunt était intelligent c'est
l'audition c'est ce qui était pris et
non des succès dans leur à une ruelle
d'euros
puis j'ai dit mais je te paraître 200
pièces christophe à l'audition mais tu
fais pour vrai le différend vouloir
entrer dans la tente au maximum
j'ai gagné mon pari je pense que je ne
sais pas si je le dis c'est combien de
fois j'ai voté pour toi 200 x 200 m elle
doit placer deux réseaux j'ai mis deux
cents pièces sur lui moi à moi tout seul
avec l'album d'eux le cash des albums
qu'on vendait par l'enquêté en date mais
le mettons deux ans plus tard en 2019
tout ça c'est fini pour vous autres
c'est un peu loin derrière vous avez été
à décrire d'autres choses mais je dirais
que dans les dernières années c'est ça
je pense que c'est la plus grande chose
le plus grand récif actions de moi je
pense de ma vision de mon année ça a été
justement de réussir a pas enlevé
l'étiquette mais de la balle à polir
j'ai collé l'étiquette quand même façon
un point de vue extérieur j'ai
l'impression que quand même bien réussi
à enlever les disques je les ai enlevés
parce que je laime moi je la sais si je
l'assumé ouais je les assume très bien
l'étiquette au départ ce que j'assume
que j'étais là j'assume j'ai laissé y
est eu plus de monde qui te
reconnaissent quand madame au dos dès
maintenant je te dirais que c'est
maintenant c'est ce qu'ils font c'est
que c'est un peu de tout comme la
musique les podcasts au décès comme un
petit un mélange de tout cela je pense
que à ce niveau là j'ai quand même
contente pisser sur le moment pas encore
là bas ça reste que c'est une des plus
grosses c'est une des plus grosses et
les réalités au québec
comment la faire qu'on va avoir fait
dans nos vies avoir été vu par le plus
de monde voire probablement en même
temps c'est probablement ma timidité je
pense que c'est ça ce n'est des migrants
de fierté
cette année puis aussi que j'ai pas mal
fini dans le fond j'ai presque fini
l'album le mon album solo mon premier
album solo hausse tient enfin j'ai fait
des mixtapes on faisait on faisait des
conneries métier comme l'album groupe b
que ce tgv 2 mais c'est au final le
premier vrai jour
aux délégués que tu es mon extrait c'est
el haouès était logique
le premier gros big ouais j'avais amené
ce mot jetables j'avais emmené ma meuf
chez lui ça le faisait ça me donne est
décédé commencer puis posé samedi auprès
du monde qui font paître même pas
l'émission le reste ne l'oublient le
domaine honnêtement j'ai fait un prix
même le cd + du oui pour voir ses mains
ce genre de conneries qu'on faisait de
la musique slam à miami mais moi je
connais pas ça
ces quinze jours de musique
judas hectares principalement j'étudie
en musée que j'ai appris c'est sur piste
et dans le fond moi depuis sorti de
l'école je gagne ma vie en faisant des
gays dans le fond ce qui fait que je
fais ça tu as for sim chez dguig de band
est une pop j'accompagne des artistes je
sais qu'il faut que je sorte à la fin
puis c'est semaine de ma vie même est
fana qui soit vraiment puis je peux
douce un peu aussi le soin de réaliser
l'album de dunes fixées par yann moix
une auto composteur qui gêne le qui
commence ma forme est sorti un single de
jeu puis l'ont fait un pays fou de
bonnes les tons sont bonnes ça va sortir
bientôt en attendant bon j'ai réalisé
l'album de mon ex copine il y en a aussi
que ce que je suis vraiment fier six
semaines c'est quand on sait que les
plus forts musicalement 2009
je préviens musicalement oui et puis
enfin l'album d'eliane est vraiment fier
vraiment faire ce sont le fait de la
bonne musique chose qu'on a fait la
meilleure musique qu'on est capable de
faire au moment où je fais on s'est
vraiment on se surpasse
en fait ce qu'on pouvait même on le fait
on fait rentrer les quatuors à cordes si
dans ce seul jeu mais par un même tout
l'été on va entendre dans ses murs à
lille nancy on a fait le plus bel album
qu'on pouvait faire les deux ensemble
avec bercy n'ont pas nié la guider mamma
mia c'est soit que ces gosses et cole
c'est vraiment gros signe son contrat
drive mais n'en faites il ya plus de
prod qui fait le canton à auch le nom
ouais je cherche plus jeunes semaine le
camp même de loin puis il ya peu de prod
qui d aussi bonne condition qu'ils aient
autant de dates c'est là on le fait
moi j'ai pas fait toutes les dates
compter comme deux guitaristes à séparer
mon poste le métier mettons toutes les
dates ensemble c'est comme qui se
massent en show
de l'été pile après de noël c'est le
personnel moi je peux lancement effectif
quand même vraiment souvent des choses
il ya des années déjà fait - un peu
parce que j'ai comme couper certaines
affaires que j'aimais - si je fais des
années à faire du resto-bar le genre
archibald par new style tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps jadis et des
années que je dédie ce faire outre 200
ch chante aussi le sait d'autre à faire
que tu fais tu es tu calmes et on tire
au but gardé par un finger avec ton nom
ton pied est capable de jongler que des
lames en feu sur ce disque à la fois
défendre la musique de ta bouche à
bouche
tout est capable non mais il fait le
guet non mais c'est impressionnant même
parce que c'est des fois on réalise pas
encore mais dont nous on est pour moi je
fais ma musique je suis mon article je
mange le visage de mon argent tout mais
toi qui fait juste la guitare mais pas
qu'il fait juste la guitare mais dans ce
sens il fait de la guitare piqué qui
t'accompagne tout le temps plein de
monde différent de gagner ta vie
convaincu que tu gagnes ou tu avis que
moi kiki combien vous faites les gars
nous apporter c'est quoi ces l'année on
voit s'il est vrai que vous avec les
est-ce que vous avez triché et riche et
à l'épaule il m'a dit qu'avec le george
thomas vit bien je suppose tracy mais je
pourrais être relax qu'avant mais petit
squames intériste pourquoi ne pas suivi
ta passion bcsa même où certaines
richesses saisie mais ces sautes paraît
maintenant c'est qu'il céderait ce que
je disais tantôt autres c'est comme we
had et où puis débat même nous ôte avec
des chocs on fait peut-être mais le plus
longtemps que je poste le plus que je
peux pour faire ce que j'aime jouer
n'importe quoi c'est sûr dit avec les
tonga d'amour
ça paraît non mais c'est vrai tu sais
pas moi même
il ya plein décision que je prends dans
ma vie que c'est pas la décision qu'a
choisi mettons des fois j'ai le choix
maintenant trunking qui est au repos qui
vont payer 400 pièces d'accompagner un
artiste que j'aime vraiment ce qu'a fait
ou ce qu'il fait pour la moitié du prix
puis des fois je vais le prendre cette
décision de lancer parce que c'est ce
qui me nourrit ce nom mais nos justes
very foule à faire là où cela si je peux
faire des tonnes mais qu'est ce que j'ai
sur lesquels j'ai travaillé par gérard
ans j'ai piqué que je crois au projet
pour ce que j'ai fait de la musique à la
base même pas juste pauvres pour être un
mercenaire la musique pour la musique
c'est quelqu'un qui s'engage et pour
faire la job mais qui que ouais qu'aucun
hypothétique et qui créatifs ou kiki
sens qu'il était enfant ça je pense
vraiment que c'est un quelque chose que
qui transcende nos domaines respectifs
le geass des juste être heureux dans ce
que tu fais pitié largeur l'argent
notons qu'à compter de l'argent mène pas
le bonheur techniquement c'est vrai
jusqu'à 75 mille pièces par année et
ceci comme des études qui ont montré que
le bonheur arrête d'augmenter après 15
minutes
mais ce qui est quand même pas mal
d'argent mais le bonheur réel qui est
pas matérielle - mettant mon rythme de
vie qu en ce moment le qui dans un
appart à verdun que je paye ma blonde
moitié montfort quittant redire julpan
ferrari le team et qui est correct qui
le fait que j'ai tout le temps de la
bouffe vu que je peux me payer de temps
en temps des restos mahmoud ce jeu
pourrait vivre comme ça toute ma faute
une vie puis je serai correct fait une
fois que tu réalises que tu dis à mener
la croissance infinie j'avais ce cette
conversation avec jay du temple
autrefois avant c'est pas de castres on
a juste eu les chaque fois que je parle
à dieu sait comme soit en podcast
peut-être aussi que ça n'a rien que la
place parce que chaque fois qu'on arrive
dans le studio
on s'assoit on s'ouvre une bière mes
tongs angela
ça vient et on parle en temps c'est
madame si on est un podcast mme dj set
et lui en ce moment dans sa vie des
opportunités il y en a à l'infini tout
les producteurs de show de toutes les
chaînes de télé au québec en ce moment
sont intéressés par du temps toutes les
chaînes de radio sont intéressés par du
temple tout les gens qui font des web
séries sont adressés par juste en tout
les réalisateurs de films sont
intéressés par tout le monde était très
sévère du tout dans tout le monde
il rêve pour n'importe qui à n'importe
quelle porte dirigé ce projet là il
frétille mais dit qu'est ce que tu veux
faire de plus cités parce que lui ce
qu'il fait triper c'est le stand faire
le podcast alors des conversations pida
fait qu'il dit le moi j'ai évidemment un
contrat comme au décès de l'enfant
restait pipi fiat est probalement que
des corps est bien celui d'enfants aussi
normalement qui gagne très bien sa vie
lui doivent bah oui définitif mais moi
je peux pas je peux pas m'en prendre
plus parce que dès qu'on truc qui me
rende mon pru ou en avoir plein mais
pour l'instant j'ai pas besoin de
croître à l'infini j'ai pas besoin les
faisant d'elle une fois tu sais c'est
cool apprécier tous besoin et ce titre
là je le faire deux fois back to back
the story cardiaque et non le jeune est
né à lyon on va se calmer un puits tu es
moche non placement cette wii 2 déserté
il ya des affaires qui sont cool mais
l'argent c'est vraiment pas ce qui
devrait motiver toutes les décisions
vraiment positive où ce sera une autre
affaire je sens que ça c'est une autre
fierté de cette année ce qui comparé à
la première année que je prenais tout ce
qui passait parce que j'ai mangé reçu
ouais c'est aussi au début de la
première année du lapin crétin bruno les
geeks brune oui mais moi j'ai eu des
geeks brune menacé d'en douter serait
même pas de musique des geeks mettons à
contre quiconque mais si broche à foin
c'est juste ok ça prend lui sa voix
d'écart avait vu qui est connu on le
paye pina titre mais savent pas trop
quand vous autres vous portez une place
qu'il est finalement le kit de sons et
des petits tout croche le même pas
musique ça existe faire une conférence
qu'il faut aller parler du véganisme
puis nous notre conférence où le
véganisme si on parle d'éthique animal
plus d'environnements féconds penseurs
des abattoirs puis affaire le décide et
coll on nous avertit paris blessés des
enfants 50 me défouler gentils dit
qu'ici s'intéressent à l'environnement
personnes qui ont préparé une conférence
le tarif non une conférence préparée ont
la peau préparés spécialement pour cela
mais comme on ne s'était pas fait ça ça
les quêtes le crowd fait que mettre
conférence mais ne l'a pas adapté mais
je suis dehors je trouve très bien que
dans 1 devant un écran qui s'est offert
un geek peu importe c'est quoi devant
enron qui est que tout aucun rapport tu
peux même faire un show ces femmes et on
rien faire un show drame qu'ont ce que
tu te ramasses effet jouer des gros big
dans un mariage et personne ne s'en
soucie des guides pour être le meilleur
dans ton domaine là toi si tu te fais
plein gré dans un souper je sais pas
quoi mais c'est parfait ouais vous
faites des chômeurs
un jour d'école primaire justement on a
fait aux cga dans un cégep et ce
téléphone par au début on n'était pas
trop sur l'iphone les cinq nominés
non c'était vraiment le fun pour vrai
mais ça c'était dans un cégep sur
l'heure du midi puis c'était potes
n'étaient pas une heure je pense qu'on a
fait comme une demi-heure piste est
quand même déjà mère d'un fils prendre
des photos qu'ils ont faits coexistent
exagère c'est cool c'est à dire ces jmj
mais non écoles primaires mais ça n'est
pas question car ici nous on était tous
car longuè longuè fabiani musicalité
mois passé nous ont calé tout cas mes
tantes et on a des tonnes comme vraiment
plus plus qu'ils savaient pour toutes
sortes d'histoires y en a des tonnes
vraiment peu un peu plus aux rites le
ticket pour des enfants 5 e quand même
année en italie on a fait la guerre à
plat se déplacent belle ouais place
belle on a fait quatre tonnes pour la
raquette quatre points c'est l'hécatombe
des fautes et fautes soit qu'ils ont
décorée par faire juste on pensait
automne tac tac le plus clean je croyais
pas de mots est possible parce que c'est
quand on est arrivé là bas si on les a
faites j'ai réalisé parce que raconte en
effet on pense pas à ça mais le fait
qu'elle est on le sait contre le peuple
en est le fait un bouquin j'ai voulu que
je disais c'est moi on les a modifié ce
le spa 103,4 mons n'est pas suspect mais
j'ai toujours réussi à creep sera pas
changée belge srt jeu capable de jeu
capable de m'adapter à un situation mais
j'aime sous parler d'appareils salle
puis dégueulasse j'ai réalisé dans
douche dernièrement c'est celle à tous
nos problèmes ce que je rappe quand vous
la faites le caire ap avant rodez
qu'inquiets ou la faisait l'autre jour
je n'en bouge plus j'ai comme je les
rapides et les noirs dans mon virus le
dire comme je le disais je dis à chaque
fois je le faisais le noir est sous la
douche
nana on avait un show qu'on faisait
avec un projet de couvrir le fort à
chaque semaine entre bord mais c'est
notre chance net j'étais comme une
brosse laisse quand même parti que la
guerre ayant toutes les chances à vapeur
qu'on faisait nos problèmes qui le lie à
la primeur de l'héroïne qui faisait face
à chaque fois fait il y avait les noirs
dans d'al-wefaq légers qu'en fait fort
avec la juste pour de justes pour dr
david parce que parce que je connais le
veuf par carte
j'ai comme fait trois fois remplaçant et
noir de parfaire le piquant mais je le
connais en baisse de rythme non non non
non non vraiment pas souffler à se mêler
pour y aller pas de casque en effet pour
le pitchoune que tout était l'animateur
la mamie accor annonce est bon pour
aider oui mais bon beaucoup de foufoune
domine la paume de main mais pour de
vrai de vrai on fait des jokes
mais j'ai quand même enlevé la vie -
cinquième set en couple piller georgie
j'aime ce j'ai mené toute rattrape
j'aime la mode mais j'aime la semaine
ces thèmes le romantisme
[ __ ] moi aussi c'est désossé de la
bourse je m'excuse à falluja le bloc ce
genre on entendre sans région en état la
région mais on a fait un shopping auquel
toi-même podcast ici c'est pas le temps
de juger
mais non on a fait un choix en région il
y avait un gars qui étaient pas il était
pas qu'ils allaient déposer la borie
j'étais comme un mic gadget en dessous
mais c'est comme se protège les rouges
avaient pourtant c'étaient les routes un
animal bien le dire le poids supporté le
poids
c'est vrai que c'est pas le temps des
jeux bien des fois où votre code ccim et
on s'assied dessus ça ressemble à quoi
votre auto tic entier que les stations
tout vous aux tripes c'est plutôt des
jeunes garçons en boîte 15 les annales
font ça va ce kit insulte tout le temps
comment ça va jusqu'à 17 fax et des
jeunes garçons baudis est quasiment 80 %
de votre auditoire jeune garçon waouh
c'est à peu près 80% si des femmes en
othe 18 secteurs en amont croit pas
vraiment car ce monde début vingtaine
surtout des filles début vingtaine des
gossip university toutes sortes d'hommes
en effet que je m'attendais une fois ce
seuil mais c'est vrai qu'elle mène le
combat mais le crom l'attendait job tu
es trop de succès les commentaires des
façons qui écrivent sur mon dieu quelle
manon mais j'avoue qu'en sur métaux
comme le podcast on n'a pas dès que j'ai
le petit jérémy jérémy gabriel oméga les
commentaires c'est un moment visé les
commentaires étaient souvent des
événements
qui écrivent sur parce qu'ils pensent
que tag est derrière l'ordi mois peuvent
écrire ce qu'ils veulent mais ça même si
on peut en parler ça m'a décoché dans
toute cette histoire là je ne peux pas
croire que il ya eu autant de haine
qu'ils soient dirigés vers un individu
gratuit parce que même dans l'histoire
mike ward s'est pas jérémy gabriel tu
poursuis mon coin non c'est l'école
c'est la commission des droits de la
personne sait pas gérer me gabriel s'est
pas jérémy gabriel qu'on m'a coincé mike
ward pour la liberté d'expression qu'on
le comité des droits de la personne
commission des droits de la commission
des droits c'est ça c'est seulement
quand même la famille de jérémy qui est
déposée mais si comme c'est finalement
c'est comme les tours qui pousse à la
inquiets proférées envers les
commentaires souvent cocasses n'avait
qu'à pas de sens moi au début je voulais
les engrais c'est moi qui le carl d
enlever je t'en ai parlé ce que je sais
par léon les amis je comprends je
comprends vos points pis si ça l'aide si
ça dérape est plus que ce qu'ils
auraient enlevé encore parce que y'a
personne qui mérite la tête avec
l'amendé commentaires qui disaient à
jérémy du tout et c'est enfin là je peux
comprendre qu'ils n'étaient pas d'accord
avec un enfant de avec toute cette
histoire ottomane on est tellement tout
écrit n'entend pourtant d'un bon que nos
pigeons on s'en fout ça qu'on l'a invité
on voulait changer mais d'attirer les
pendant l'été mais les communautés
changer avec lui cette peine le jour à
20 qui viennent un podcast contourne le
podcast la fin de l'appel était pas si
c'était fini je suis vraiment venu la
ponote l'indication semonce r j'ai eu ce
jeu les textes et chute toi j'ai fait
est ce qu'on est sûr que ça se passe de
- pretoria sion a dit waouh je pensais
moi je me disais monclar de ta c est
assez vieux flama n'y ai pas vu par tout
un pays est assis est assez mature pour
comprendre que moi je prends pas
position le circus - 29 ans je la joue
sur un stand dans ma tête de donner un
juge hugo potes à petit jérémy pu
discuter avec lui plus grande ce coup il
fait de la musique sont ça reste dans le
temps mais ça reste un thème spécifique
à riscle
en plus à la caisse on n'a pas pris de
position je peux lancer de position
invariable riel uni en voir à quoi
retenir avant les droits de la personne
n'ira voir la liberté d'expression moi
je fais juste écouter les ruelles poser
des questions c'est ce qu'on a fait
puis de voir les commentaires dont
c'était du 50 50
mais au début c'était sorti puis les
gens n'avaient même pas écouté qui on le
déteste dans le détail est possible
d'avoir écouté le papier ça faisait une
demi-heure sa sortie qu'il y avait déjà
comme 200 hommes ont commencé déjà dit
que c'était une marque [ __ ] pitt c'est
la fin et que c'est que cette fois c'est
qu'elle lui apport avoir été récipient
d'une blague ne pas avoir été en accord
de la liberté de faire ce genre de
blague là il a fait du mal à personne il
traitait personne de nom il a été
irrespectueux envers personne ni tué
personne genre à part ne pas avoir été
en accord avec la liberté de faire des
blagues sur les handicapés bien rire
c'est bien particulier en fait ouais
ouais non mais si c'est le 6 mai mais
apporte avoir fait ce le 7 opposés à une
blague qui étaient destinés directement
il rien faire il mérite de mourir
c'est fou le premier a dit lundi dans
son speech qui gagnent sont une vision
j'ai rien contre marcquois et j'ai rien
contre mika briel série pose la question
lui se bat pas contre jérémy gabriel
lancé sur facebook contre le fait que 1
e
un organisme qui représente les taux
poursuit maurice pour une chose pour
ceux qui se bougent mais c'est pas là la
question le le monde le monde y aussi le
monde projet est mitigé mais là elle
dure qui te sus des rôles que ce genre
sipa drôlerie des handicapés cdh et
bosser pour les questions la doc études
lupo c'est une bonne question de se
rassurer les handicapés au pot c'est ce
qu'on devrait est ce qu'on devrait
traîner encore une mauvaise pour une
joke cse
tu peux très bien comprise et pis c'est
cela le débat de la limite de l'humour
est quand même pertinent pertinent parce
que yoyo je peux imaginer des scénarios
où ça irait trop loin qu'il faut louer
intervenez s'est passé je peux team je
peux tu imaginer une blague là qui va
trop long trop lundi chaque que j'ai
voulu créer justice je peux passer sa
vie à la fois que c'est grave que se
requestionner notre vision de l'humain
est ce que c'est si grave que ce qu'il
ya des sujets qu'on puisse pas
nécessairement en rire
est ce que c'est si grave que cela
n'exclut pas la question c'est cette
question dans toute l'histoire avec mac
os et s'appuie ce débat là en tant que
société on se doit de la voir mais je
pense le monde en ont tellement bien
entendu parler atra les années le
téléphone arabe sont choisis personne ne
sait vraiment de quoi on parle
puis ils font juste prendre position
mais position qui me disent les gens se
sont choisi une pause sur la force dans
l'entente allait dire car on n'a pas
encore en position mort jérémy ciel
prennent position qui un pourcentage de
personnes qui ont commenté centre la
vidéo du ring gabriel probablement était
même pas conscients quand ça s'est passé
tellement de temps que jérémy gabriel
connaissent même pas avant la john
senden jamais brel on connaissait il ya
une raison colas joe kay et à
l'existence parce qu'il était connu à 26
mais choqué en a plein qui ont pris
position qui avait aucune des jeunes
enfants aussi kiki qui me fait capoter
aussi le sectionnement de panique excès
liberté d'expression liberté
si mike ward père je comprends le point
je comprends la frustration d'un côté
qui vont à kemer on a perdu pour ça
ouvre une malle ça ouvre une valve que
si après cette ouverture le le sapsan en
fait plein le seul problème mais c'est
un que ces six blessés ni chez c'est
comme c'est pas à cause que mike ward
parquet mois précédent même atteint chf
hentchag 19h quelqu'un qu'elle est
je sais que certaines personnes fassent
plus attention c'est la seule afrique va
jouer c'est sûr que c'est plate de se
démettre un filtre surtout pour vous
autres je connais rien en droit aucun
jugement qui tombe il ya un précédent il
ya une jurisprudence qui s'écrit puis ça
fait au québec dans cette cible de trucs
le la norme si ce métier
visiblement notre regard de ce que se
coller le lion pas j'ai pas l'impression
qu'ils veulent faire un exemple de ce
genre pas que j'ai pas l'impression
qu'il ya perdu en appel mais comme y en
avait quand même quitté dun il avait
deux qui étaient peu nombreux à vous
rencontrer mais en voulant dire je pense
pas que ça va ça va changer le cours de
leur look et betty pour pour revenir à
la question qui est posée c'est une
guerre que suscite des trucs sur
lesquels ont pu faire de jack je pense
un peu oui parce que je pense que je
pense pas qu'il y ait droit des sujets
tabous intouchables du quai lors
desquelles on n'a pas le droit de parler
des piquets de seul le solde dont le
seul fait de prononcer ces mots la tdg
de s'agiter avance je suis d'accord je
pense je pense par exemple que c'est
correct dans une société qui est ce que
tu dis quelque chose qui cave même pas
de la joke hamac je parle juste si tu
dis quelque chose qui cave
mais aujourd'hui les gens ont plus la
possibilité de répondre puis ça c'est
correct pis le fait que le fait qu'ils
ne sont pas d'accord avec toi qui te
disent certaines si c'est pas bon ça
c'est pourquoi on ne peut pas être sûr
c'est juste parce que tu sais quoi
c'est quelqu'un qui essaie d'être
censuré seul e mail à sa semaine est ce
que légalement si légalement ça tombe un
verdict comme ça ce serait de la chanson
je sais pas je peins aussi légal ou
illégal
la définition même de sens mais c'est
parce qu'il ya une grosse différence
mais ton si on peut rire de tout le mais
mettons ces obligations
remettons dire jérémy gabriel mène 4 et
à la fureur de chanter mon beau sapin
s'était pas fait ça quelque chose c'est
affreux
je me sens très à l'aise de rire de cet
événement le temps de dire de la fura
pas nécessairement l'oreille qu'il faut
pour chanter détourne de même deux
paniers le chemin de fer poignet le
chien puis dati était nul à chier
pilates c'est un moment de télévision
qui est super drôle d'attitude quai des
tuileries de sousse rire de ce mois je
trouve qu'un gros step est en train de
s'opérer entre rire de leur ire de vos
ennemis qui est arrivé et puis aussi
exposé une personne a été publié il faut
que tu t'attends à ne pas exposer faut
qu'ils s'attendent à ce que quelque
chose qui est en toi peut importer qui
n'importe quel joueur
c'est sur ce soir faut qu'il soit quand
même prête à ça parce que pour être fort
c'était juste pour ce qui est je pense
que ben quoi le cas un bon point c'est
parce que c'est jérémy gabriel temps
voulu à fedj errih me aubry a longtemps
voulu être exposés de voulu être
quelqu'un de connu tu t'ai connu on
parle de toi tu assumes je comprends ce
point est le bon de là à vouloir le tuer
le noyer je sais paul et moi ça a été
mon personnage dit le problème aussi
dans un dépanneur pour pour plusieurs
c'est la mise en bouche de la
formulation y est pas mort lui talent
mais qu'est ce que la mise en bouche de
cette formulation là que ma couette
utilisant sa blague bleus je paraphrase
n'était pas exactement sur mes soucier
c'est trop facilement réutilisable à
chaque fois qu'ils apprécient reviens
parce que si si si si je n'étais pas
morte ou tabarnak je te cite la blague
ou si je l'écris noir sur blanc fumé les
guillemets autour ça pas de la drôle
dans tout métier
sisi mcquaid 10es de l'agglo un show une
tournée temps exactement ce qu'a marché
exacte une blague marche pas comme ils
sont chauds et ça c'est pas drôle mon
trip au jeu la coupe la blague dans son
contexte
fonctionnant dans la bouche de cet
humoriste moi aussi je sais très bien
que tu m'as pas non plus dit jérémy
abriel sans doute été victime des gens
qui ont attendu sur quatre ans mais
c'est sur la face parce que si personne
ne l'avait soulevée ouais ça reste une
blague dans un show puis cette formule 1
on l'aurait jamais des tirs la réponse à
offrir faisait son show devant un public
averti dans le public c'est simple je
pense qu'il le dise aux oliviers en plus
ces indices crise vous en parlait plus
c'est aussi la récupération dans les
médias qui fait qu'elle est devenue un
sujet de société qu'il est si nous avons
de tout le monde qui le legend aller
retour de jamie gabriel c'est soit que
s'alarmer
en plus des mots dans la bouche par ed
ou un prétexte de plus vous acquérez est
incertain legault c'est plate c'est
triste à dire mais c'est sympathique
rite pareil je sais pas ce que dit mon
mac un enfant cas très différents
tu sais que réglé que par le québec au
complet nous avons l'équipe compte mais
parler les p'tits gars l'école parce que
c'est ce que ceux qui quitteront empire
venir chez vous puis avoir du monde
quitté le box n'étaient pas mortes au
montât barnat sud même si ce mémoire que
je lève mon chapeau c'est ce que pense
qu'on devrait clause essentielle parce
que on a parlé j'imagine pas commun qui
sont et qui a raison de s'en faire
parler le mot juste fait un podcast avec
ce que c'est juste c'est que des mesures
parce que ça fait partie de tout ce
qu'on était à chaque année au québec
qu'on parle de disney débarquent ici
juste à la ligne wait & see comme étant
catherine dorion j'aime me gabriel
il ya des trucs qui sont juste à licques
non non mais des bouquets ja you kiss me
demande un bas c'est ce que 90 % à 10 %
comme un jardin 51 hauteur de 50
ces mots j'en parle si j'en parle à
quelqu'un il va être crise ma première
course mais si j'en parle à ma tante
avait plus pour régénérer
jérémy gabriel pialat des bons arguments
aussi dit que je comprends pas je
comprends vraiment les deux côtés de la
médaille
dites moi je serais même peau d'adam la
position d'un ou l'autre j'agirai pour
comme un ou l'autre parce que de chaque
côté et des fanatiques un peu comme moi
c'est là que je trouve temps de l'averse
une coupe des fanatiques de mike est
aujourd'hui majoritairement les
fanatiques la haine même qui s'est rendu
compte nous
mais j'ai reçu aussi à ses ordres compte
nous on demande qui voudraient peut-être
faut-il snitch les vols commis à la fao
si c'est pas compliqué le pig avons sera
pas facile là dedans des commentaires
site est assez stupide pour écrire les
enfants comme tu toi vous êtes démarre
bla bla bla puis s'était même pas
capable d'expliquer un point pendant le
pas combien pour moi tu es juste un
imbécile ça compte pour rappel dans les
heures suivant la vidéo puis emmené
ajustons à condat toit d'un mot marie
nachi qui répondent à certains
commentaires c'est comme enfin
commentaire qui fait du sens commun qui
comprennent deux fois merci carmen de
lavaur des volumes de lave ont invité en
écoutant sont ces points je trouve
t'elle telle affaire lafarge au podium
et au moulin vont s'expliquer c'est
d'avoir pris le temps d'écrire un
commentaire pertinent d'étudier un
commentaire je s'expliquer même si t'es
pas d'armes juste bien formulé le pays
expliquent ils pourquoi un peu au lieu
de gérer ce type vidange
c'est intéressant si le côté fanatiques
qui sont beaux à jérémy ce c'est une
genre de ces particuliers en crise c'est
comme l'a fait à mes écrits je trouve ça
vraiment plate je crois que c'est une
bonne personne je trouve torride jérémy
gabriel le choc pardon je souhaitais pas
de casse je n'ai pas senti trier lui non
pas du tout facile à chacun maintenant
je ris pas de dalian
c'est lui qui m'a poussé à se jeter
comme l'âge invasive c'est un peu je
peux pas mettre ce sud du lot ce mais je
te jure qu un jeu de ces forts hockey
fih genre des fois j'ai dit oui malgré
un fake et tu es dans ta face et et puis
tout le monde y est c'est à dire merde
j'ai entendu pas mal pire que ce je
pense pas que pensez vous du genre à
cela je n'avais jamais entendu je
l'avais jamais attendu
les terrains des morts c'est comme ça
façon à comprenez par là était tout le
temps c'est comme si peu importe ce
qu'on dit à jérémy on est content lui le
m
ce que demandait le véganisme au
quotidien salue tous ça doit être un
autre mais tous deux patates on année ça
a été super ça a été une grosse année le
studio se fait pas longtemps que ces
partis se fait peut-être mais certains
titres dont on parle de musique m'est
témoin de l'époque je collais ce mafia
c'est pas de casque studio parce que
c'est vraiment ça fait aussi le sel a
amené un genre de s'alarmer genre de peu
plus et mettons un peu tout ce que je
fais ma tante est ce que je fais ma
blonde c'est un peu à part parce que le
ca commence à partir pour vrai qu'on a
travaillé longtemps dans l'ombre
fort de cinq ans à partir pour rsa c'est
vraiment au fait que j'ai ensuite
réfugiée pendant crise merci merci est
encore disponible exclusivement mais
monsieur je sais j'en suis fier mais
mais le studio puis le podcast pires que
ça s'est rendu le fait que maintenant
pas avoir nicole qui est qui est
derrière la cam nou qu'elle vient de
dominer de s'élever piscine mais ça sur
le wild qui viennent ainsi à la vague de
violence
mais c'est vrai mais le frère me nicole
s'il ya des concerts derrière les
consoles
vous l'avez déjà vu plein de fois au
sans fil on en a déjà entendu parler
même fait une apparition surtout pas de
case élysée nadeau nongo j'y reste à sa
charge 50 du studio tu faisais vraiment
comme le podcast sans fil
qu'est ce que le studio le local hockey
qui tout ce qu'on fait dans le calcio
je pense qu'elle tende un juge si vous
je pense que le temps ne joue je suis
rendu à un espèce de must dans les robes
tubes ce milieu qu'aux vrais ma vous
avez reçues toutes les plus grands noms
il est juste là qu'il ya là quelques non
conformité à recevoir le mérite mais je
dois tout
une incontournable
je pense qu'il s'est rendu
incontournable si je suis vraiment fier
d'avoir participé à créer soi même s'il
est plus difficile à monétiser par
définition à cause de ça à cause de ce
que ye pied sa cause contre lui ou pas
de s'inspirer des bols en janvier ça
devenait lost et steq sommes devenus
fait légale en janvier c'est faux je
vais même pas le même pas qu'ils doivent
garder à sucre très moiré longtemps et
c'est parce que même si les plus
harmonisées qui ont fait pas d'argent
avec en soit mentir le
vraiment le fait que ce soit devenu ça
c'est vraiment hâte je suis vraiment
fier de genzyme ce qui c'est qui qui
tentent pas de casque à casque il
fonctionne super bien qui bien écouter
en audio vraiment c'est quand le monde
nous envoyer leurs here in review de
sports fr
c'est juste des podcasts du sf ça s'est
vraiment amusé mandjeck tettey
soulageant les autres c'est sûr que m ce
qui nous envoie ce que c'est vraiment le
temps de jeu j'ai vu passer rien qui
avait pas aux moyens pas de diass de du
studio et celles ci n'ont eu outre hall
après celle et à combien de partir qui
est en bas de casse plus féministe plus
de niche et je trouve ça super cool puis
au delà de ça tout le monde lâche
maintenant pour pour louer studio tu
sais c'est vraiment là que les voir la
job bientôt ouais c'est ça mais non il
ya tellement de bons pas de bon pas de
casse en fait le qui se donne je trouve
ce temps je sais pas s'il ya eu comme
une jordi aussi une vague incroyable de
tafia si on dit qu'ils ont débuté il
faut que je pense que le fait que vous
ayez parties se à ce moment le sa tombe
et elle est charmante et et comme nous
en mettons début printemps dernier m
ouais ça je pense que le timing idéal
parce que un podcast qui est
professionnels comme ceux qui sont au
studio sfr ne peut ni rapport il y en a
peu 6 1 à d'autres je les connais pas
nécessairement son venin bureau ce qui
nous est que ben radio de cessation des
institutions mais même c'est pâques à
cela sont pas écoutés de ces chèques non
c'est super cool non mais c'est vrai
très vexé ces noms c'est ce cheminement
faire des copies c'est le permis aussi
de s'étendre on parlait de faire ce
qu'on aime ceux ci leur à ce corps ou
qui est qu'ils sont un commanditaire du
podcast aujourd'hui je trouve pas non
sur popote
ouais le chocolat noir et vegan il peut
contenir des oeufs contenir ça veut dire
que c'est weill en fait qu'ils ont dû
chocolat vegan leur second enfant un
garçon en fants blog au milieu du
podcast mais je pense qu'on est saoud
d'hommes fait comprendre qu'en ce moment
on va juste ton jacket
fait que dans le fond c'est ça c'est
hélas accorde son commanditaire toute
façon on en a sûrement pareil déjà en un
troll mais mewes effet calaisis ligue 1
n'a que sa forte liège merci selon paris
qui est qui non mais non mais non je
redonne aussi on est deux là dedans pour
nani que maintenant on est cuit semences
fier d'avoir une école avec nous mais
nicolet le trophée actifs ces deux
langages à temps plein qui avait fini
l'école unique à l'année prochaine fois
que tu vas rester si tu peux être payé
ses bénévoles trouve mais des fois le
déploiement de faire des trucs bénévoles
ça paye après plat je dis pas quand tu
m'as tu fais là la mine d'or la mémé
mais comme c'est un projet qui offre un
produit qu'ils font mouche et que
j'avais si j'avais eu le job comme ça
j'aurais été content crise là nestea je
dis moi j'écoute et nous et les podcasts
pour être exporté que désirait pas tout
ce que tu produis piano'cktail qui
rejoignent non étanche à l'intérieur
mais
pièce et lequel temps préféré lorenzo
mais c'est bon parce que je mène école
il aime beaucoup les big black mb les
faux si je l'écoutais l'eau fois et cela
avec karl artifices on t'avait sont en
vue d'un versement il t'appelle tu
appelles nos techniciennes huawei watts
c'est bon rien que ça c'est un pas de
casse bateau pour ceux qui écoutent
c'est un podcast qu'on produit ici qui
s'appelle big black kent biolay fausses
et de drag queen c'est gabriel et c'est
gabriel comment comment il s'appelle
gabriel barbade actions de drag queen
qui sont à montréal puis il faut un pack
assure soient plaints de cellules t
c'est super cool du tout que ce soit je
devrais plus en plus de rides ou roschy
game de me déguiser en drag-queen venir
votre podcast serait un pixar mais je
suis d'abord et puis me rappelle je vote
oui mais voilà fait que fait qu'elle et
sa fille de restaurer le chiffre fait
beaucoup de bien je tapais sur jérémy
n'est qu'elle m'a écrit après jérémy
grimm a dit le lendemain matin il m'a
dit m
hier j'étais un peu chaud je trouvais ça
drôle en tabarnak mélo mais ça c'est pas
de casse le c sur la presse et que les
40 points - je n'en ai parlé d'amour
puis j'ai fait mes recherches sur comme
sait les dates de coopé comment castrés
passer du temps avec ma coin puis
j'avais vraiment adamo le j'aimerais ça
comme que les délits 34e minute l'on
soit sérieuse de paca slots et puis
qu'on essaie on laisse jérémy par les
pions et je fais que j'aimerais en fait
mes petites recherches des choses qu'on
fait pas tout le temps d'habitude
ouais enfin que je trouve que la moitié
du podcast c'était bien c'était quand
même sérieux puis on parlait des brèches
puis les brestois qui sont pensés puis
après ça a dérapé fab savin bon et qui
les passent des ponts dérapent trop à
cause des juges
ben si c'est le temps des fans en
faisant ses commettants top 5 des pas de
casque et de produits jusqu'à mène
maintenant parce que le sel ça fait un
peu loin
2010neuf aussi le temps restant à
produire demain 2019 mais je te dirai
qu'ils ont péri dans ton cas puis
c'était au début des bus en c'est le
premier que tu faisais je pense qu'ils
me sur le 1er 2e 2e 2e j'étais vraiment
particulier passe-t-il après après si on
est sortis oui c'était assez personnel
maintenant comme conversation tu as fait
avec comme un lien avec était non mais
ce qui était faux qui en fait c'est qui
ce qui motive je la connais c'est juste
parce que je la suivais sur internet
[Rires]
devant chez eux trois heures à chaque
soir non mais je connaissais déjà
je me suis sentie comme si ses katas me
parler je me suis je me sentais comme si
j'ai entré à l'intérieur d'un film mais
c'est vrai mais ça le fasse de l'effet
de vue que tu tombes un podcast parce
que tu reçois toutes sortes de monde du
milieu artistique fait que tout doit
être ip l'internet mans pour et moi
c'est ça que j'aime de co animer le
podcast c'est justement leur saumon qui
sont dans le milieu artistique nous
autres banques et c'est beaucoup plus
fière durable il ya de la musique aussi
mais ça doit tester car on vous a rendu
à quoi 70-70 podcasts sont associés 69e
non non c'est le 3e c'est vous avez vous
avez reçu tellement de sortes de monde
du milieu québécois que c'est moi je
trouve moi je sais qu'ils me paient tous
le trip et vols de films soient requises
en ce temps là jérémy grièvement et
brille en est un autre
ça va demeurer en vrai que je regarde
les podcasts qui sont sortis c'est
quelqu'un aura avec thomas levac demain
évacués
vraiment tripé west ham en l'évacuant
joint au mieux la messe s'est auto city
du monde quand ça nous écrire pour
fournir ici tellement les vaccins
humoriste qui nous a écrit bondir sur
les podcasts et billets sur place le
bagage est aussi le lieu un podcast
l'étang des jujubes avec une
anticipation faire des rotations si vous
êtes tous et toutes tourné juste et même
aimé ça être le seul dans ce cas cela je
pense qu'il rendu à 150 c pour un
podcast national de gier pas de caisse
de n'est pas pour vous saluer parce que
nous adorons notre notre niche c'est
vraiment de la musique tu sais c'est
vraiment musicalement fax et on n'a pas
de youtube heures on n'a pas d'influencé
pas des personnes beaucoup de rappeurs
c'est majoritairement des weppes et
qu'on a eue ce moi ça me faisait capoter
mais je m'en doutais acac sont rentrés
le première chose c'est même pas les
enfants sont arrivés ces genres le chef
de sécurité h f
j'ouvre la porte regardez qu'est ce
qu'il fout là je l'avais rencontré
aujourd'hui autour de la villa je leur
ai dit l ego alésia line je bouge je
vous dis là les rôles mais non mais
c'est parce que je savais que ça venait
faire un stone ses sources et les
anciennes halles in any officer mais je
pense que ce serait me roll it may
aurait pas comme il se serait peut-être
senti mal
quand je pense qu'ils seraient pas allés
aussi à l'émission qui ont été tués je
leur ai dit allez-y menant à l'île aux
puces et de susi et détruit après ce
podcast locked up à mal le sida vos
règles qu'ils causent
j'ai réalisé leur est en fait basé j'ai
jamais j'ai jamais voulu avoir le
contrôle parce que je sais que je
pouvais juste jamais l'avons enfin que
je suis comme vous n'êtes pas de casque
et à face mais pas trop quatre schémas
n'y a pas trop de tripes et je l'avais
promis d'être seul avec un 4e qui disent
la barre qui courent pics sont comme moi
g kg
segel je m'attendais à voir prenez le
manach ouais je m'attendais pas à voir
la chute inédite vient du latin qui
commence à insulter tv jantes et le
stocker plus sur le jeu puis moi je les
connais mais je les ai toujours vu sous
leurs habits wallon sont arrivés que les
ravisseurs sont partis quand le podcast
fini c'est bon c'est un juge veut mener
ça fait une heure et dix ans déblatère
de la marde les télés le temps de la
renommée une chipie moelleux le long jeu
remettre quelque chose au club je
suppose le défenseur du cannabis ce qui
fait que l'arrêté me suis-je pas un vrai
peut-être on a eu l'idée
parce que je traite un muscat but des
bonnes on va le faire mais moi j'avais
jamais pris de jupes de mahfoud suivi
jamais de ma vie je vous passe une fois
des biscuits mais j'ai jamais vraiment
pris les jeux je pilote c'est quand j'ai
fait mon premier podcast
en fait ma première journée de podcasts
que j'ai réalisé aux riches et d'un
cochon sont embarqués parce qu'après le
premier pas de cash était complètement à
elle limite la limite de ce que je
prends durée la loi parce que je n'aime
pas c'est une crise d'anxiété
le soldat arrive de coco rasé ce type et
à tous d'en face je viens de là oui je
le connaisse odieuse par facebook lui
arrive complètement agents puis il me
répond dès le début un genre entrevue
radio canada je pense que je crois
qu'après une hausse non plus comment ça
et donner de l'amour genre leader des
belles choses parce que j'étais trop
horrible je viens de me taper un
deuxième jeu blanc
j'anticipe déjà que le 2 et chaussures
pour embarquer la clé après celui que
j'ai commencé à me dire j'en ai
maintenant que je me sens en barque et
puis depuis ce temps le depuis qu'ils
ont fait le pas de casser on est rendu à
quoi 39,9
depuis qu'on fait ce je sais pas je me
fais approché le tout le monde et comme
bons spots la question est simplement ni
villa ni sur une référence connaisseurs
yuma l'occasion je ne peux même pas
chaque jour quand je suis brune je
prends une pauvre en bêtes mangent les
facteurs suis pas un potez mais ça me
fait juste rire de voir à quel point le
monde sait les médias qu'est ce que ça
peu facile le fait que
je représente le podcast le temps d'un
jeu blanc c'est comme automatique lui on
a accès à ces ailettes leur montre une
parcelle de tout et ils savent pas les
skis partenariat local qui doit être
jugé dans la tête tout le temps je
des fois le jeu marche dans la rue le
monde me croise le dg gibles drogue toi
tu collabores acides les jeunes moi j'ai
juste les pourfendeurs podcast d'intérêt
depuis comme c'était juste un concept
qui ont trouvé qt
si au lieu de fumer un joint parce que
dans le fond le ski est arrivé c'est que
ph m'avait approché dans le temps que
vous partie du studio puis tout lui
m'avait dit si je sais que pour le pour
le hip hop il ya une bonne partie gens
qui seraient intéressés d'avoir un
package pour ça ça marcherait on a fait
trop de casse avec je pense j'avais fait
un peu parce qu'avec le coriace puis
carrias réveiller le faire métier on a
fait car ya trop de berlin fu qui vous
avez déjà fait ce peuple vous avez bien
que père je me disais qu'il ya comme du
monde gens veulent du tueur enfin je
pense qu'une place pour un podcast pour
les papilles étant donné qu'on se
connaît chez que tu en fais une année
j'aimerais surtout que ce soit toi tu es
moi j'étais un peu timide potes puis moi
je disais c'est tout bonnement parce que
je sais que les rappeurs ça fume
débattent sans ça c'est super h c'était
pas d'armes ne savons pas comment cette
relative débauche c'est le nom le plus
ironique c'est que son clean c'est josé
s'est pas tu vas commencer à ce que
savait comme les via les juges bleus
pattes les la peau de ce différend sans
doute si qui viennent là winch et c'est
cela
non mais t'es bref pâques les jeudis on
peut pas fumer ainsi un peu de pub vous
fumez de potes je sais plus lequel des
deux qui exigent que les bulls ont fait
7 c en peluche tout salaire - b est
comme freddie hubbard
ça fait ça fait ça pue site puis j'aurai
enfin ça fait plus classe et ça fait
comment qui écoule tandis qu'un jeu jupe
c'est cute
ça donne le goût en fanfare du spot non
mais tu es non mais c'est seule la
raison plus belle profondeur
ok on a participé c'est ce bref et en
gros je m'attendais pas à ce que ce
déjeuner au palais des tamales à l'acte
en tout et puis chaque fois qu'il vient
ici tournait pas de casque qui va
exécuter il dit il est drôle à sa
manière de parler en plus ici c'est
tourner le meilleur package de tous les
temps le temps de juba avec les
anticipateur le liant par le pilote les
passionnés bleus tout le monde comprend
rien
zillow illégaux y arrivent sont déguisés
le ils sont commandés du direct grimpe à
castres en imitation là des fois dans
des imitations sont choisis par 2 gold
limited fait plus penser que c'est la
bonne personne celle ci
ce qu'ils doivent savoir qu il ya des
fois des résultats sion sont vraiment
shop ce jeu là même c'est la seule façon
de pratiquer à venger va affecter ses
podcasts mai
1 ces semaines les finalistes jean une
enquête pas d'insultés adamo toulon de
policiers je vous rappelle lilliputiens
lips insee
ch je pense à ces sommes n'ont même
somme que j'ai su ce sujet pas de bons
termes mais est ce que met on les
appelle match comme n 'est pas cassé à
l'arrière
j'étais à huy en psycho osment blanche
et les risques qu'est ce qui se passe et
ce que je mette un terme à ce genre
en plus c'était quand même un des
premiers va être celle des buts c'est
donc qu'on donne à spatiale pas fini
c'est ce qui en a d'autres qui vont et
quand même légendaire qui s'en viennent
si je sais que c'est comme celui du
petit jérémy c'est quand même il faut
que j'arrête de jimmy briand
c'est quand même ça risque de passer les
annales c'est ce que j'ai donné un jour
mais c'est ça mais l'ego iep lille et
elodie plus de celle qu'on pense ouais
honnêtement le team suis pas surpris
dans le sens où je m'attends la soif
fois quesnoy qui met dans son souci je
m'attendais pas à ce qui passe rien on
va star chez les pacers meetic en mousse
l'obligé pas d'armes était exposé à
longueil monde cham
j'aimerais bien ça même s'il y compris
vraiment ce que tout ce qui ce qui peut
ressentir en fait qu'un givelet trop de
sens que si je juge les il s'est
tellement fait détruire dans les
commentaires c'est ce qui vit
constamment
c'est ce qu'a écrit en plus un message
privé me dis merci de m'avoir même topo
castrais agréable et on se reprend en
contre-haut l'aveu puis
j ai dit je te lève mon chapeau pour
ipad titre est habitué en espérant que
ça nuise pas trop à ton podcast
je donne tu sais pas si énorme scène nue
poule jeu des limites ça fait juste
parler du parquet a supputé mais c'est
plus pour toi les jours je me sens mal
d'avoir invité tout avoir exposé comme
se piquer le monde dit il soit aussi
comme méchant toute honte bue mettons en
évitant c'était quoi bon mon but c'était
juste stone s'est jamais njamen à
l'image où l'ordre est le petit jérémy
jamais le petit jérémy jaunin je joue
bottes moto était subi c'est tout le
c'est tout le mois je voulais pas
commencer à mourir et s'était même pas
d'amis plein parler de mike ward nous on
n'avait pas le choix parce que là ça
n'est pas la décision venait juste de
passer je vais être honnête avec vous
autres je savais même pas que j'étais
encore en course des sources était fini
j'étais sûr que c'était moi je pensais
que c'était déjà réglé que je pensais
déjà que michael avait payé je pensais
que c'était bien c'était un mauvais bond
ma vie est bon en même temps l'arrivée à
paris mais un autre parcours change de
sujet nos podcasts dans le gym que j'ai
fait six dernières consoles qui agite
quand le sm'art iman simone qui mène à
peine arrivé avec une faillite avec une
fille ça dérange suspense sur le corps
de mon ami du roi d'abomey la fixation à
côté mais la première chose qui fait
peur par cas c'est long mais c'est l'umq
première chose qui crée pas ne sont pas
un sou 30 ce qui est d'un résultat
fidèles lapin se prennent les yeux qu'il
a publié le mois la pose une question ce
que les machines clé pour ceux qui
savent pas c'est moi qui fais ce boys
boys band est un artiste pauvres et des
bazars passé juste payer leur vue que le
podcast et longtemps et qui comme ci
comme ça dit-il fait dit-il golf et des
mutilés jet les faits les murales et
très léger bon petit parcours métiers
y'a pas passer au fait qu'est la vie
alors avoir de la peinture des yeux
pendant 2
pis parle beaucoup ces premiers nous
fait aimer la vie qu'ils allaient à
epagny les yeux fermés c'est la couleur
des yeux puis continue l'année elle
savait que j'avais déjà il parle plat en
afrique dada il parle par le malus quand
je regarde et je pense que je peux
couper - kim jong il comme la fille
quitte à coup ça fait quarante minutes
qui est en souffrance la fille à côté
qui était comme l était pas un débutant
pas de calais vos mamans préféré le
groupe de mamans qui vous ont marqués
outils des conversations vous avez eue
avec certaines personnes que ça vous a
vraiment marre je commencerai par dire
qui est le fait de faire le podcast les
gens qu'on rencontre puis les échanges
car tu es dans les champs le site
intéressant tout les podcasts champ du
temps d'un podcast agents y est c'est le
fun mais ça l'est vraiment l'impression
que sam changes puis sa main packs pour
seulement au quotidien parce que parce
que c'est tout du monde
inspirant petit monde qui conquit qui
réussissent dans ce qu'ils font plus du
monde qui ont trouvé où justement
comment faire pour pour être bien vu
pour que leurs affaires marchent dessus
fait que l'enfant tout en bleu maine
inspiré puis genre en voulant changer
des affaires vous souhaitez je pense à
ce que je me dis hein et telle personne
a fait à la faire tel ou tel supplice a
pity ya du monde qui nous écrivent
qu'ils disent c'est recevez des ceux du
monde peu connu de ses pilotes
évidemment on n'a pas la notoriété pour
être capable de recevoir quelqu'un
personne connaît pixels que ça permette
de continuer à croître le podcast
c mais il ya quelque chose aussi de
recevoir du monde qui ont réussi parce
que du monde qui ont réussi c'est pas
pour rien si la personne qui ait réussi
par hasard fait que toutes les personnes
qu'on a rencontrés qui ont réussi dans
un champ et qui y sont en train de
réussir et route
c'est tout du monde qui ont quelque
chose à quelque chose à dire qu'il
fallait me l'apprend aujourd'hui par
intéressant puis qui sait pas c'est pas
l'angle vedettariat qu'on vise le titre
c'est vraiment de recevoir du monde
intéressante je pense qu'on sait
exactement ce qu'on fait parce qu'il
fabrique tout dit et la croissance
personnelle qu'on en retire
c'est vraiment cela grosse affaire les
honda fois que j'ai appris mais promet
le podcast nombre de choses que
justement j'ai changé dans la ville dans
des rangs de belles rencontres que j'ai
faites n 6
c'est incroyable mais moi ce que je suis
ce que je voulais dire c'est que ce que
je trouve intéressant du sans fil c'est
vraiment le fait que ces deux j'avais
vraiment toutes les sphères s'est pas
uniquement comme j'adore le poker est un
jeu j'adore farceur mais je réalise que
tranquillement bohème emmenez jean paul
goude invités de route monde mais c'est
comme un peu c'est comme un peu de cas
qu'on sortait daudet le y avait même
cette chaise le gojira
on a des origines pour 2020 médecins
sortants daudet moi je m'en a mené
j'étais confronté à ce qu'il me suis dit
ok si je fais juste des story de mopi
jesse may stade continue à grossir c'est
bon et il a neigé prix les gains bord de
dire hey joe a commencé à parler des
trucs moins stricte
pis j'avais perdu mon soi que amené
cette perte love arrêter le savoir
commencé à grandir sur des bases que moi
avec lesquels moins confortable
si toi si vous obtenez vous détaille
dans un juge bleus on sort du rap que
vous allez perdre ce soir vous avez
perdu membres dans l'immédiat mort du
monde sont qui veulent juste entendre
parler de rap ils veulent que vous
receviez fu chi une septième fois
travaille seul mais ça mais vous devez
être cette fois même moi j'ai envie de
recevoir du mans
qu'ils prennent déjà passé le concept et
moi j'ai envie de recevoir fokine
françois lambert sur un juge bleuté vous
allez perdre vous allez perdre beaucoup
de monde de votre crâne mais en ne faut
pas rester prisonnier de votre corde il
faut décider de sa voix rauque et moi
même je vois des conversations
intéressantes pendant 40 minutes puis je
veux pas m'en 25 minutes après ça
déconne avec du monde de toutes les fois
qu'un milieu ben fait ce fait cela c'est
sûr que vous avez toujours resté proche
du hip hop c'est vous autres fétiches
c'est sûr que ça va toujours rester
comme une trame narrative du podcast
peut-être on va perdre du monde dans les
premiers épisodes c'est sûr mais
peut-être qu'un homme soit reconstruit
du monde on va se reconstruire
tiens following des gens qui veulent
entendre des conversations même autour
de juin avec du monde qui sortent un peu
de hip hop c'est ça se passe la limite
c'est juste comme ça on va moins
monétique et des peuples
ici c'est pas la seule chose qu'ils font
des millions d'autres termes le sport
qu'ils aiment d'autres à fort alamo 2012
et pop ainsi un monde particulier
explique nous souhaitons mais pourrait
non je cite je suis conscient mais c'est
juste que c'est quelque chose que j'ai
commencé à penser le dernièrement parce
que j'ai fait mon genre de un peu comme
le week end de l'année j'ai fait mon
genre de comment je voyais 2020 j'ai eu
comme écrit un peu ce genre mais réseaux
sociaux je la fais toi seul de nos côtés
noah avec ma blonde mais parce que j'ai
besoin de quelqu'un qui quand même tu
auras tu aurais pour mémoire mais
j'aimerais sommes partis un calendrier
de moi tout nu à tout les maux georges
comme quelque chose en thématiques et
que l'amour avec moi
2021 au quai jusqu'au bout mais j'ai le
planifie projet quasi landrier man que
je vais le chercher comme andy je me
disais viguen mais pas plate
si on va s'emparer pour 2021 mais si
j'ai le budget marketing pourrait
prendre pas de toit à poil sur douze
pages le budget moi ce que j'aime en
quête douce pas salée calendrier
commandité juste un mois tu peux
commandité juste pour moi je veux le
mois où est ce que tu fais la même pose
qui est pas vraiment personne qui avait
fait le truc pour pilotes qui étaient
masqués complément toutefois des gestes
la poêle puis à des grossières mais qui
avait pas besoin de fourrure mais ça
c'est bon lui veut se mettre à poil pour
absolument aucune raison a dit moi je
tape comme elle souhaite a toujours aimé
ça que ça à poil pour aucune raison
elle m'a rappelé ma blonde vu sa graine
blonde a vu son agréable on a vu ça
depuis quasiment avant la mienne vous
lui avez vu ma gagnent deux fois je
pense py qui en était à odéon un tel
ensemble
adamo était debout sur le dj set à côté
de moi comme d'un moment mode à green
card amour sincère unis en sens inverse
comme tourner en vraie grandeur mots en
fait j'ai comme créature aujourd'hui au
moins c'est comme si je ne réfléchis pas
j'agis
ouais c'est un moment à grain maintenant
de réfléchir
j'ai redit pas s'avancer mais c'est ça a
été mais je pense c'est mon charme
non pas vraiment mike green
si mon chat non non non non non non
c'est pas mal mais est modeste
non mais si je trouve que on arrive à
quelque chose le vertex c'est juste que
contact association mais chaque classe
aphrodisiaques
les lyonnais c'est vrai je reconnaisse
un frère jacques oubliez pas de ma faute
je commence à parler des axes non mais
pourrait ne pas manger de chocolat noir
si bleu sur la qu'il ya seulement des
traces à ses seuls c'est lui qui est
vive et un merci nos attaquants enfin
que dans le fond à tâtons mythe mais ce
que je sais juste pour dire que j'ai
quand même une certaine le sait qu'on
sait ce que c'est mais quand je vois un
pénis généralement je trouve cela quand
je regarde le mien ça beau je trouve
quand même beau les cours se nomme était
sur scène narcissique et wec deuxième
essai comme ac ce livre et je regarde
mon bébé comme qu'ici ça prouve juste
que tu est hétéro ce que tu viendrais là
c'est juste parce que tu étais autres
ouais fascine 11 m découvrez tout
trouverez boutre s'écouler contexte où
tout est prétexte bien même les mettait
pas les derniers travaux beaucoup mais
c'est parce que moi en gros c'est avant
tout un gros bug mais pour vraie vérité
ne sais pas ce que je suis ici et je
trouve ça je trouve ça vraiment plus
mais il ya plus de monde qui sont
circoncis que ce que je croyais en
vieillissant mais expliquez moi comment
ça c'est fait
bayon coupé à toit mais d'enfoncer la
décision de passer mon bac pro en gros
la vérité c'est parce que mon papa père
qui était jeune il ya eu lui se défaite
circoncis mirador chose comme 8 9 ans à
cause que son pénis est grosse
ils sont plus gros souci c'est ouais ça
pulse grossissait pi 7 po non non pas
que les il pouvait pas comme du pénis de
son défunt papa n'est autre que pif à
clé ça y est les eps a aisément soir là
ça faisait pas mal hein c'est pas que
lui il s'est dit j'aimerais passer que
monfils 10% à 10 ans à göteborg
je pense juifs le ca par rapport à mon
fils
non mais pourquoi j'ai trouvé ce j'ai
trouvé se trouvait ça cool parce
qu'aujourd'hui je regarde ce que je me
dis je contente qu'elle se contente pas
avoir fait là on va parler des parties
non mais c'est la décadence tu as tu
mets ton juste pour un épisode met on y
faisait son malheur dernier aussi le way
jamais être quoi le temps d'un jubilé
partira on est preneur mais je joue
d'ailleurs que ça serait vraiment des
singes un opéra ton truc de beauf le
toit or on en garde un studio pour vous
enfiler sur le temps de jeu
merci leurs attaques mais pour vraiment
bon c'est ce qui me dérange assure la
presse c'est qu'habituellement je pense
avec les boîtes de même état comme le
petit livret qui dit quelque chose comme
passeur je me lance pas trop la langue
ne trouve pas que c'est mal c'est la vie
c'est comme une boîte de chocolats g à
l'écouté parisien où comme faisaient à
nos invités du s en fait mon grand père
disait toujours au bout cage la vie est
comme une boîte de chocolats c'est vrai
que boukari est connu pour ce site est
grave c'est toujours taxant le bes sas
en est un bon cru avez vous vous en fait
on l'a on savait d'avant avez vous un
top cinq top-3 de pro b c'est sur la
dangereuse je le sais tu le dis tantôt
même option parce que je comprends que
je croule rapidement le jeu la liste le
touriste est cool c'est vraiment un coup
d'oeil skype ça a été le plus long
podcast
la première fois que j'ai regardé ma
montre je regarde ma montée à chaque
minute mettons pas parce que je suis
bonne chose parce que je joue mais la
progéria maman tu as caché 45
on est vraiment on est vraiment tombé le
solide dans le trou mais y aura vraiment
chier mais à ce que de s'enfoncer le
monde mais descendirent il n'était pas
utile puis maintenant il y apprit à
potasser nombre d'enfants et il a parlé
internet on n'a pas parlé puis à pala
son show vient de parler sur podcast lui
avant apparemment qui était détestable
j'en remets ton devant la caméra il y
avait d'autre que le pitch il mais qui à
bien des signes répétés des cochons
monde ou techniciens piètre monde autour
de lui même n'a sa famille était faut il
était pas fin avec fait que changer une
prise de conscience puis un genre de
week end qu'il est en train de détruire
bandai perdre ma femme fille de perdre
ma carrière qu'il faudrait peut-être que
change de coiffer clients j'ai consulté
puisse guérir de cette espèce de deux
d'addiction à être un trou de cul locke
avait lancé m c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est lui qui le dit mais c'est ça ça ça
semble sa démarche semble vraiment en
attente comme je lé senti vrai et
transparent et authentique
ouais c'est oui mais tu en a qui peuvent
être vraiment comme devant la caméra
bien hors caméra si on a tout entendu
des histoires on peut en parler des noms
qu'on a entendu maintien on entend des
fois on s'est fait dire que si cette
personne lost artistes et marques métier
ça se peut aussi que l'huile après une
coupe de cheveux ou le vin chaud en un
mois l'a vu il ya eu une mauvaise soirée
ça s'est pas bien passé ce soir le
pilote belge technicien cacao qui a
écopé d une fois dans la journée à
supprimer 4 réputation est un joueur qui
est tout le monde en parle ça arrive ça
arrive ça arrive je peux juste d'
affaire d'état une mauvaise journée ça
va faire de problèmes à régler
néluge plus semble-t-il que ces soupes
semble-t-il que l'équipe parfait mais
qui
qui est vraiment s'améliorer puisque
travailler là dessus puis qui sait bien
que c'était bon sinon mes tongs jusqu'au
métro moi le pharmacien c'est vraiment
ne pas mâcher olivier bernard axa pe qui
il garde les la science de vulgarisateur
scientifique et qui délivre une émission
sur tou.tv puisse y explorer qui prend
des sujets qui mettons zaki maintenant
l'homéopathie c'est quoi se situe vrai
si tu bosses et su prouver
scientifiquement ou non qui l'aï voté ce
qui est intéressant c'est chaud sur
tou.tv de plus écouter leurs piliers
s'est livré est trop trop quatre livres
ou si c'est vraiment intéressant type
glock yaya pris la cause des défauts ce
parce que thil et plus en plus de
fausses informations sur ce nouvel
dessoude de la santé qu'ils soient des
modes direcement des modes santé voient
une oeuvre dans le vagin
c'est un exemple donné c'est un exam et
lo'jo d'un journal y avait donc enfin
c'est vrai il ya plus en plus de mode
sport rapporté davout de plus en plus
internet puis tout seul afin d'engager
jamais entendu mais non mais je pense
que je connais pas la jeune compagnie de
trucs des produits santé que alternatif
le nom pouvait non noté qui soit a
conseillé de la fin d'un mois le 10e en
tant que moyen de même mais j'ai autre
chose il y avait l'article dans le
journal du mont part ils essayent
capoter m'ont pas les matières en plus
et il me dit lis ce genre qu'il est et
comme une nouvelle mode chez les
influenceurs weirdness l'américain de
genre écartez vous les jambes nues au
soleil puis genre foot face gris anono
soleil n'en voulait dire à nos amis mais
une chose est sûre même seul au jazz à
vannes discussions précisément par
rapport à choqué par ce que il ya un
gars qui luttent pas de casque six
équipes qui s'est mis à me parler de ce
parce que lui avais vus passer l'article
puis à fait mais ça c'est la paire a
frôlé moi j ai dit tu mènes me semble
mais tellement tabarnak passieu du monde
qui qui disent le véganisme c'est une
mode plus j'ai dit mais tu veux parler
mode le se faire griller rim au soleil
wells on n'a pas ces normes se seraient
fiancés
ça peut passer d'un mode de vie socio
mode de vie mon goût on part tous les
affaires de mont wright
c'est pour ce motif à grill truc qssl le
mécanisme est inévitablement va devenir
mon écurie mais de plus en plus à force
d'en parler de tout ça c'est que c'est
stupide le gipn mai
tu vois rien que rien que boire du lait
ça doit faire comme trois ans je bois
puis le lait chaud ou un pitié j'ai
quand j'étais jeune j'ai toujours aimé
l'ep tout ça paie du lait darolles je
pensais à force ça force à force d'en
parler à poser au vu des vidéos puis
tout cela qu'elle pense pas rentrer
dedans je me suis dit l'homme alléger
les dames en 2 rennes 2 j'étais comme
chris emerson le lait d'amande j'avais
moins de difficultés à digérer puteaux
depuis ce pot je touche pas au vigan et
je pense que c'est ça plus t'en parles
tu deviens sensibiliser plus tout en
informant un peu ça va peut-être pas
changer tout autour de sa personne mais
oui je n'ai je pas se changer
ici l été prochain on se garde mon homme
c'est ce programme c'est parce que c'est
parce qu'il est lui à force d'en
entendre parler de ces mots j'en parlais
tout le temps l'uspo du lait il boit
encore du lait mais mes dirigeants
parlait tellement tout le temps d'un
podcast manica les arguments sont
inévitables tu crois sont dridi suscite
ce type d'arguments dont la durée a
réfuté c'est ça la bonne décision la
raison c'est lui qui a raison
le chaque fois je manger de la viande
jeter comme si on faisait le buzz pas si
je vais préparer pris part samedi je
prends train de faire la bonne chose
c'est clairement nui iv ça a marché à
bout du mans jetait pas le choix on
échange et irrité mais c'est depuis au
débat lille bat tout aussi
définitivement mode pc ça j'ai dit je
n'en avais pas qui parle autrefois
visait jesse may blond a lui eu un
impact énorme ça alors aucun sens
ça n'a aucun sens parce que tout le
monde maintenant même roxane bruno
apparaît autrefois tu la première fois
qu'on l'a su par cassetti moi je
supporte plus de manteaux de fourrure
mais parce que jesse en a parlé
ça c'est que ça tellement des
répercussions le monde le monde que tu
regardes que tu de l'ordre penser comme
toi même ton le tout le monde que titre
dans l'ordre que tu vois qu'ils adhèrent
à quelque chose comme ça puisse à sa
part de loin mais à quoi bon des
répercussions tcc pas nécessairement
direct mais directement à fort et un
fort présente des vues d'influenceurs
d'influents ce qui a une influence
positive somme qui devrait impacter
fanta les tea party une bûche en fait
une tournée de buch quand elle porte une
bûche hadji du tampon casino trépident
j'étais là avec une valve dalpé qui la
productrice de l'eau des puits ceci dit
c'est sans danger s'il n'y avait pas de
kate cette année ses 100 jessy qui
arrivent là en disant moche pas sexuel
chez une diversité il n'y avait pas de
kate cette année mais là à prayssas
enquête cette année il y aura pas de
wade veut ça va être la prochaine chose
h1n1 homosexuels parce que soudain
nicole qui a un certain soin de son
identité sexuée rigole qui se découvre
encore chaque jour là ils viennent
s'ouvrir une khâgne et comme les trois
sociaux je suis en train c'est dur sans
connu autrefois les rideaux étaient
ouverts
saleh qui plombait y avait là ne
s'écarte le hockey mais c'est bon c'est
esahara ouvre des horizons et le dépôt
obligé d'être d'accord avec tout mais
juste d'avoir une ouverture d'esprit
puis on auprès de t'informer puis
d'écouter puis le reste après ça tu fais
ta propre opinion mais je pense c'est ça
le problème quand on compare les reins
qu'avec la fois de jérémy petiot d'en
reparler de ça c'est juste quand tu
laisses un commentaire de marc c'est
juste la haine plutôt pote points à
porter c'est juste c'est pas mal et ça
comporte pas très juste écouter le
mont-de-piété projet d'accord pas
d'accord mais l'ouverture d'esprit mais
c'est une évacuer les plus importantes
de quoi se la curieuse sur l'ouverture
d'esprit mène les vertus universelles et
plus importants que moi je dirais que je
suis le gars honnêtement que y'a
tellement rien qui me dérange
avant quelqu'un maintenant c'est quand
qu'il est allé là bas ça me dérange pas
je trouve ça le fun limite le match de
ne jamais être content quelqu'un jamais
d'une le monde que ça ne dérange ils ont
besoin de se regarder longuement un
miroir mais ça ne fait pas tout mais
c'est pour ça que ça peut faire défaut
c'est frustrant tant sa lampe sur gardot
damon c'est quoi
mais moi c'est ce que je me rends pop
côté du monde dans même sauf qu'en bout
de ligne c'est ça plus tu penses à
pourquoi les gens pensent comme ça plus
tard jamais je n'aurais jamais la
réponse c'est là où je peux dire que je
m'en que c'est un gars qui est vraiment
indifférent jeudi autant je suis
indifférent face à quelqu'un qui s'en va
au dic et qui quitte france autant jeter
indifférent aux commentaires négatifs
que cette personne va recevoir comme je
trouve juste que le monde de rome de
phoques dan doit accepter manu relaxé on
est on est souvent dit les exhume nous
mêmes tout les reste deux jours mais
pourquoi tout capote tout ce que ça va
deux fois ça te faire les ulcères mon
groupe séché l'anus ne sais pas trop
mais jamais cessé cicig à saint jean et
moi je trouve que ça m'affecte mais ça
m'affecte pas en même temps je sais pas
comment expliquer qu'un sous-marin dong
est vrai dans le fond je vais je pense
tout cas n'est plus là je m'exprime pas
très bien en ce moment là même temps les
mayas mais ça fait ça je sais pas main
dessus je me fous de tout mon poids je
me fous tout d'une façon et que je me
crise de tout mais je dis ça me
dérangerait que pauleta t'empêche pas
tant mais je pense que tout le monde
décide piscine raison c'est pourquoi
qu'on reçoit du monde à des podcasts
qu'en soient toutes sortes de monde
parce qu'on est curieux on aime ça mais
j'aime surprendre les autres des eaux
des personnes qui sont justement celles
phone [ __ ] est différent plus
intéressant oui demander quelque chose
est à prendre
c'est comme le racisme exemple ceux ci
n'ont parfois quelques jours je ne
comprendrais jamais le caecum là ça va
c'est comme on dit que le racisme comme
le début de l'imbécillité c'est là que
ça commence
comment ça a été fait en 2009 non mais
parce que c'était vrai ça veut dire que
c'est sûr ça m'inquiète d'autres petits
points le genre à -30 lui c'est sûr
c'est sûr que c'est quelque chose je
comprends pas cette fesci bhl ceci comme
tu ta touche disait pis tandis qu'angers
deal
jérémy morel sera décoré par egis peau
qui j'ai des bonnes ni qui mérite de
faire crédit que ça devrait être comme
se met lui même les enfants c'est du
manager de chez les enfants piano qui
reste à ce stade l'on dirait
tu es différent ben je te méprise ou jeu
mais je redoute ta personne le fait
d'être ans août il veut pas n'importe
quelle minorité visible très différents
ta religion quoi que ce soit différent
si sincèrement tu es rendu mat ont rendu
un vrai adultes étaient touchés par 22 à
23 ans un vrai adultes quelque chose qui
te dérange au pdp fait juste peut-on
touristes et gens là ils laissent les
vivres auprès des préfets des choses que
je peux d'accord avec ce puits comme ça
me tape ça n'a juste pas la face à face
assez probable du monde qui est dans
leur vie dans le vraiment c'est pas dans
les réseaux sur un conflit non non mais
dans leur vie sont pas exposées à ce
parlement car non pas des gens comme
ceux dans leur entourage me noie un plus
pour ce mail les réseaux sociaux
l'internet puis les médiaux les
confronte à ceux ci je ne suis pas et
exploser sinon c'est parce que dans la
réalité immédiate
il ya po sont donc je pense que c'est ce
je pense que quelqu'un qui a grandi
quiquet qui a grandi à montréal
quitte à lui une école multiethnique
avec toutes sortes de toi dany autour de
lui n'est pas raciste la majorité du
temps il est habitué à ce qu'ils
connaissent eux y met quelqu'un et
j'avoue de ce que j'ai grandi j'ai
grandi justement ceux de montréal je
sais pas peut-être qu'ici mais dont
j'avais grand mail est ce parce que le
sien ça revient au même c'est comme si
on disait que le monde des régions sont
non mais c'est pas ce après que ça
revient souvent les responsables des
différentes monnaies responsable des
comics qui a gipsy demandé des sillons
vide est un truc ue non mais mais je
pense que c'est le moins exposé à de la
différence le plus tu vas être réticent
4 être confrontés ceux ci ne me donne un
exemple mais non vraiment con que je
pense pouvoir parler de dieu mais que je
trouve que c'est un point quelqu'un qui
m'a valu ce point là j'avais préparé
c'est que dans le fond je fais je peux
le tourner avec un autre artiste qui
équipent aux québécois qui plus est
maintenant algérien woippy
il m'a dit on va faire la tournée vous
deux ensembles un ensemble conséquent
que vous allez en région - varrault du
monde qui se disent pas ce que lui
algérien qui sera en région font pas
leurs hôtes
comment ces régions sont plus non ça ne
sort plus sans plus c'est le sujet une
grande généralisation
un point qui quand même c'est un point
qu'il faut calculer dans une tournée
pour l'étude de marche
l'étude de marché est clair le pis s'il
ya des points et des stats qui lie pro
c'est un film mais c'est juste que je
trouvais ça quand même
sinon il remplirait pas de sa généralité
qu'on peut tirer comme ça mais après ce
faux faut pas juger quatre 4 x 4 bonne
partie des régions vous assumez l'aurait
cru mais moi ça me détend de 106 normal
qu'après pas un billet ça ne coûte pas
sa musique c'est déjà arrivé
moi je vienne québec ont vu à mon école
il y avait une chinoise à l'école point
noir les doutes adopter et adapter ses
seins pays par les mêmes français je
parle mais puis ça arrive d'aider
situation parce que par admob qui ont
gardé à montréal québec ottawa et québec
mouchoirs du québec ces radios ex-pc la
cacp icc québec plus de droite au québec
puis tu es comme déjà pré perçu
présupposé que pensent certaines
monnaies requinqué après ce chaque
individu 6-4 contre un individu
quand tu pars de zéro le même peu
importe de ton âge
dans la vie je fais confiance à tout le
monde l'agression s'est passée de la
trouvera
si elle fait partie d'une généralité
aussi est bon ou pas bon et les boys
avant de frapper ce on va faire un petit
tour
qu'est ce qu'on souhaite pour 2019 en
je souhaite que les deux prochaines
semaines 2020 excuse moi ouais je vais
avec le bon vieux classique mais c'est
vrai la santé même du bonheur notre
joker c'est ce que je me souhaite ce
soit je vous souhaite tous pour vous et
puis de l'argent en troisième quand même
à l'aide quand même un oui ça c'est vrai
que le bonhomme et la santé plus
important la santé la santé vient de
réussir des histoires d'horreur john key
qui ont même pas frappé 31 janvier sempy
plus enviés santé toujours du monde dans
l'entourage plutôt depuis plus je pense
à soi puis vraiment de la fin avant tout
peut bien sûr des réussites d'un toutes
nos tout ce qu'on va entreprendre chaque
qui vous autres aussi bien bas n'ont
rien d'un gars comme toi avant rodez
rodez à des patients dr bonne et juste
mettre cartes sur table non si vous êtes
rendus dans le podcast jusqu'à
maintenant que vous voulez que d'hommes
faso des météores time's up dans les
commentaires du pape ya sublet caisse
comme souhaite pour 2020 à entre dans le
fond apport en septembre décembre à
penser cap mollo a rencontré des filles
qui votera quand ça se pourrait maroc
imagine y annonce où lé maroc
comment ses hôtes mais mais j'avoue je
dois je peux pas comme je dois confesser
que cette année je check est
depuis deux ans c'est pareil je me dise
quand même une expérience humaine
incroyable
genre tu apprends sur toi un homme à la
sortie de le changer
tu changes et je t'ai je dors plus le
dandy dans des caisses desjardins le
tableau non mais pour rien au job c'est
vraiment une expérience incroyable mais
je dois avouer qu'il me faut pas six
mois qu'ils disent quand même une
expérience si quand même
jamais je ne savais pas de casser les
clichés des certaines sa zone de confort
mais ça c'est l'ultime sortie de kung fu
l'ultime phase de luxe connaît pour
l'argent c'est pas ça repart un autre
fois ça madame août vouloir compter vous
abonner aux pitchouns exact fait que
sinon je te rue ça va bien ça va bien
j'aimais paix intérieure qui est à la
recherche d'eux que j'ai pas encore
trouvé il faut que je trouve la paix
intérieure en plus que ce fait au maroc
entre la souhaite réorientation un peu
de carrière je sais pas parce qu'il ya
des affaires que j'ai fait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup que je
connais qui aurait joué beaucoup
deuxième du championnat va au delà c'est
un tabou qui décès ok mais
mais c'est toujours l'exemple que je
donne mon métier j'ai dû jouer
housewives mille fois dans ma vie en
jaune ce sans compter les pratiques
ouais parce qu enfin pour être prêt ce
qui a rendu leur met enfin que petit et
à la réorientation jeu quand même
confiant que ça va bien se former plus
de création puis moins de djabel moteur
et beaubois man lapins des roches au
sabot wesh procès verbaux je le dirai
que j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de stress que
je me que je me crée moi même peut-être
à 6,2 d'éliminer certains certains
facteurs de stress dans ma vie je parle
pour moi
ce nom mais l'humanité ça dans le bon
sens continuez les dom alors je pas on
va y arriver mais ça c'est une fois que
j'ai hâte que tout le monde est hissène
a ajouté que malheureusement ces métiers
plus monde s'aime je sais que ces pdg de
la la voir une bagnole aussi de jean
longuet genre mais selon gayle mais
c'est vraiment sinon plus longue et je
me demande si elle miss longueuil je
sais le changement du sujet mais si elle
mais selon guy sur les bords mais dont
l'impact forte tendance et monique mais
non aux jo que je pense que c'est
continuer à aller dans la bonne
direction parce que je pense qu'on sait
rien quand même dans une bonne direction
c'est du moins on en parle beaucoup plus
on entend parler plus de bonnes choses
et il va falloir que ce soit
exponentielle mais je le confesse je
confirme en fait j'espère que 2020 votre
début de décennie qu'il veut sans ligne
dans le bon sens puis je suis confiant
que oui sinon même je dirais qu
évidemment bon le classique santé santé
amour se souhaite à tout le monde le
plus possible sur ce qu'ils méritent pas
merci les soirs mais jamais en tête des
gens que quand même vous trouviez les
faillites a détruit sa vie au tournant
pour sa part s'est acheté un canada
goose fork ton amour mais honnêtement
sharp s'en va seul mérite polissoir les
violeurs jeremic a pris à tabarre me
ah oui et puis si je les ai ch'ti
d'éloges sur internet non mais pour des
systèmes ton podcast à grésy mange mange
mon cul ouais c'est vrai rien gaïa diaw
est surtout tu manges tu as not stop me
demande mon cul je me désabonne tout le
monde les 840 mon humble avis non ça
c'est une affaire qui est bien
importante s'il s'agissait pas de rendre
tout le monde heureux c'est impossible
faki je vais assez de rendre tout le
monde heureux pour 2020 puis ben bref
c'est ça puis j'espère que les projets
m'ont bien aller pour tout le monde
puisque je leur demande c'est la base
ces cons ces clichés ce qu'était mais le
lob mais être bien dans sa peau mais
voilà est bien dans sa peau c'est
généralement quand ils viennent à
tapoter positif ça s'enligne pas mal
tous trois semblent plutôt et nicole
qu'est ce qu'on ne souhaite que moi à
fait trouvé l'ultime but dans la vie en
fait c'est juste à faire quelque chose
comme dix mois dans la dernière décennie
j'ai eu vraiment beaucoup de jobs que
j'ai pas aimé que je me suis fait chier
qu'il s'est fait logique est le podcast
non non mais je m'en a dit enfin enfin
là c'est la première fois que je fait
quoi que je tiens vraiment typique et
puis je sens que je suis cette pour la
défense pour moi pour moi c'est juste
continuer
c'est ce que je souhaite à tout le monde
merci mon dieu on est content d'avoir
une zone où se trouvaient dans le temps
des fêtes l'orientation man fait en 2026
cas de revenir avec moi je pense à ça
fait pas sentir et même quand on
s'arrête après le temps des fêtes
une coupe 2 6 3 nous avons à notre parti
star mag vous allez où
mais parce que ma foi je sais le 4 les
90 puis j'ai fait un retour aux sources
à ce qu'on vienne nous rejoindre dit par
exemple avec ce moment on sur la gueule
peu importe tout ce qui était dans
vimont somme c'est avec les personnes de
70 dates
ouais c'est vrai que c'est là que ça se
passe exquis que tu invites le petit 10
le mn viens tu as ta place ça va être le
fun même système pour le style ambiance
qu'elle a l'habitude
c'est avec la personne qui l avait la
gagne j'ai envie de finir ça là dessus
alors toi c'est quoi ton année cette
ignorance je viens de parler 2020 et
2020 pour moi les gars il ya six ans ça
va être de l'ina sam chit que j'ai
accumulée dans le dernier six mois
peut-être dieu sait faire un genre de
clean slate qui juste me concentrer sur
les trucs qui m'intéresse vraiment
est-ce que tu pas dans la vie
professionnelle majorité parce que dans
la vie dans ma vie ces fantaisies
personnelles deux pas du genre à prendre
c'est de la merde non arabe à damas il
ya eu des hauts et des bas depuis mai
mais là c'est pas mal sur un os en ce
moment puis puis c'est cool mais
vraiment d'un côté professionnel
vraiment faire le clean up comme on
disait tantôt de commencer à dire non à
des affaires qui m'intéresse pas parce
que maintenant le ce que le studio m'a
amené c'est peut-être la capacité de
plus pouvoir dire non je pense que
d'homme public peut aussi à sur le tir
de pouvoir commencer à prendre -
d'affaires qui nous tente pas parce que
c'est quelque chose que puisqu'on dit
aussi tantôt de quand même checkez la
croissance à tout prix
à quel point tu veux croire depuis gros
sourire tout le temps de calculer se
réaliser quand même arrêter de se
comparer c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est la
société d'aujourd'hui nous price et nous
pochât faire une pression sociale
incroyable qui fait qu on part sur 20
souvent ce qu'on va voir des personnes
que tu devrais juste même pas de
comparer parce que c'est différent
ce ça peut jouer sur ton moral sur ton
stress surtout sur tes performances au
lit
c'était bien parti mais mais mais mais
plus plus être années quand on est en ce
moment sur média social en bois de
castres sur internet puis sachez venant
de deux mois pour l'encadrement sur port
en témoigner qu'ils ont piqué un petit
peu de l'autre côté des réseaux sociaux
c'est parce que ça a l'air puis arrêtez
de comparer quand on souhaite un bond
tout le monde ensemble le pas de wii
sortira le 24 collectif les connaît
c'est pour jouer mais tout le monde il
est beau
j'ai évité estime l'ubs sa famille à ma
famille cet écart soit bonne fait que
tout le monde a nettement échoué